Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Places and people were connected by presences of many kinds. Places and people were connected by flows of stone, meat and other materials, but were also physically linked by tracks on trails. One might even claim that the first revolution imbuing land with social meaning belonged to Neanderthals, not Homo sapiens to Neanderthals not Homo sapiens Neanderthals first kindled history that is from Kindred a book by Rebecca Rag Sykes that came out
Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Places and people were connected by presences of many kinds. Places and people were connected by flows of stone, meat and other materials, but were also physically linked by tracks on trails. One might even claim that the first revolution imbuing land with social meaning belonged to Neanderthals, not Homo sapiens to Neanderthals not Homo sapiens Neanderthals first kindled history that is from Kindred a book by Rebecca Rag Sykes that came out|||感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的一员，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。地方与人之间通过各种形式的存在联系在一起。地方与人之间通过石头、肉类和其他物资的流动相互连接，同时在物理上也通过小路和小径紧密相连。甚至有人会说，赋予土地社会意义的最初革命属于尼安德特人，而不是智人，属于尼安德特人，而不是智人。尼安德特人最早点燃了历史之火，这段话摘自丽贝卡·拉格·赛克斯（Rebecca Wragg Sykes）于去年出版的书籍《亲缘》（Kindred）
last year and which I've been meaning to read ever since it came out and I would guess that every five years I will read a book on the subject and every five years I will find that the subject has completely changed so um Becky Ragsides book was the kind of the latest iteration of where thinking is on Neanderthals Dominic are you a fan of Neanderthals or do you well Tom let me kick off by saying that the last time we had a podcast with a guest you started with an absolutely a landmark impersonation didn't you of uh of liam neeson that's caused a lot of comment and i was absolutely bracing myself for you to kick this off with an impersonation of a neanderthal well and i think it's a it's a missed opportunity it's a sad moment for the podcast but we'll just have to fight our way back
last year and which I've been meaning to read ever since it came out and I would guess that every five years I will read a book on the subject and every five years I will find that the subject has completely changed so um Becky Ragsides book was the kind of the latest iteration of where thinking is on Neanderthals Dominic are you a fan of Neanderthals or do you well Tom let me kick off by saying that the last time we had a podcast with a guest you started with an absolutely a landmark impersonation didn't you of uh of liam neeson that's caused a lot of comment and i was absolutely bracing myself for you to kick this off with an impersonation of a neanderthals well and i think it's a it's a missed opportunity it's a sad moment for the podcast but we'll just have to fight our way back|||这本书自出版以来我一直打算去读，我猜大概每隔五年我就会读一本关于这个主题的书，而每隔五年我都会发现这个主题已经发生了彻底的改变。所以，贝基·拉格·赛克斯的书可以说是关于尼安德特人最新思考成果的一个迭代。多米尼克，你是尼安德特人的粉丝吗？还是说——好吧，汤姆，让我先说一句，上一次我们邀请嘉宾做播客时，你一开场就来了一段堪称里程碑式的模仿，对吧？模仿的是连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson），这引发了大量的评论，当时我真的做好了心理准备，以为你会用模仿尼安德特人的方式来开启这一期。嗯，我觉得这是一个错失的机会，对播客来说是个令人遗憾的时刻，但我们只能想办法扳回一局。
and and hope to win over the listeners some other way. Maybe by the erudition of our guest. But no, I do know nothing about Neanderthals. The only thing I know about them really is a massive recommendation to the listeners. William Golding's novel, The Inheritors, which I'm poised to learn is probably all completely wrong but is an absolutely magnificent novel if you if you even if you've never read any golding books for me it's probably the best but we can talk about it maybe later in the podcast well so what so so the question of how one would impersonate a Neanderthal did they talk what did they sound like I mean this is just one of the many topics
and and hope to win over the listeners some other way. Maybe by the erudition of our guest. But no, I do know nothing about Neanderthals. The only thing I know about them really is a massive recommendation to the listeners. William Golding's novel, The Inheritors, which I'm poised to learn is probably all completely wrong but is an absolutely magnificent novel if you if you even if you've never read any golding books for me it's probably the best but we can talk about it maybe later in the podcast well so what so so the question of how one would impersonate a Neanderthal did they talk what did they sound like I mean this is just one of the many topics|||并希望通过其他方式赢得听众的喜爱。也许是通过我们嘉宾的博学。不过说实话，我对尼安德特人一无所知。我真正知道的唯一一件事，就是向听众强烈推荐威廉·戈尔丁（William Golding）的小说《继承者》（The Inheritors）。我随时准备接受这样的事实：里面的内容可能全都是错的，但它绝对是一部无与伦比的小说。如果你——哪怕你从未读过任何戈尔丁的书，对我和说这可能也是最好的一部，不过我们也许可以在稍后的播客中讨论它。那么，关于如何模仿一个尼安德特人这个问题，他们会说话吗？他们听起来是什么样的？我的意思是，这只是众多话题之一
that I'm hoping that our guest Professor Chris Stringer who is research leader in human evolution at the Natural History Museum and an absolute hero of mine he incredibly kindly showed me around the display on human evolution the Natural History Museum I remember being given his wonderful book Homo Britannicus by my parents one Christmas he's got other origin of our species britain a million years of human story our human story you get the drift the person to ask about human evolution and particularly about the neanderthals is chris stringer who is joining us chris thanks so much for coming on and am i right that that you like me did a project on the Neanderthals at primary school. But unlike me, you then went on to become absolute world expert on it.
that I'm hoping that our guest Professor Chris Stringer who is research leader in human evolution at the Natural History Museum and an absolute hero of mine he incredibly kindly showed me around the display on human evolution the Natural History Museum I remember being given his wonderful book Homo Britannicus by my parents one Christmas he's got other origin of our species britain a million years of human story our human story you get the drift the person to ask about human evolution and particularly about the neanderthals is chris stringer who is joining us chris thanks so much for coming on and am i right that that you like me did a project on the Neanderthals at primary school. But unlike me, you then went on to become absolute world expert on it.|||我希望我们的嘉宾克里斯·斯特林格（Chris Stringer）教授能为我们解答。他是自然历史博物馆人类演化研究的负责人，也是我的绝对偶像。他非常热情地带我参观了自然历史博物馆的人类演化展陈。我记得有一年圣诞节，父母送了我他那本精彩的书《不列颠智人》（Homo Britannicus）。他还有其他著作，比如《我们物种的起源》（Origin of Our Species）、《不列颠：人类百万年的故事》（Britain a Million Years of Human Story）、《我们的人类故事》（Our Human Story）等等，你懂我的意思。要问关于人类演化，特别是关于尼安德特人的问题，找克里斯·斯特林格准没错，他今天也来到了我们节目中。克里斯，非常感谢你能来。我是不是没记错的话，你和我一样，在小学时也做过一个关于尼安德特人的课题？但与我不同的是，你后来成为了这个领域的绝对世界级专家。
So thanks so much for coming on. Yes, that is in fact right. Yes, I did a project on Neanderthals. I think I was nine years old. I was inspired by BBC radio broadcasts on prehistory to do that project. I had drawings of skulls in there and so on. Unfortunately, I haven't got it anymore. It's a great shame, but there we are.
So thanks so much for coming on. Yes, that is in fact right. Yes, I did a project on Neanderthals. I think I was nine years old. I was inspired by BBC radio broadcasts on prehistory to do that project. I had drawings of skulls in there and so on. Unfortunately, I haven't got it anymore. It's a great shame, but there we are.|||所以非常感谢你来到节目。是的，事实上确实如此。没错，我做过一个关于尼安德特人的课题，我想我当时大概九岁。我是受到了BBC关于史前史的广播节目的启发才做那个课题的。里面有我画的头骨图等等。遗憾的是，我现在已经找不到它了。这真是个巨大的遗憾，但事情就是这样。
Yeah, but it was the beginning of something and I couldn't have dreamt I would end up working on this for a career. So, Chris, for people who are approaching this sort of completely blind, when are we talking about Neanderthals? When and what were they? OK, yes. So, in fact, Neanderthals and us are relatively late in the whole story of human evolution. So we think human evolution stretched back at least seven million years. And we in the neanderthals are part of the last few hundred thousand years of that story so we in the neanderthals are relative latecomers and the neanderthal story really begins in the 1850s with the discovery in the neander
Yeah, but it was the beginning of something and I couldn't have dreamt I would end up working on this for a career. So, Chris, for people who are approaching this sort of completely blind, when are we talking about Neanderthals? When and what were they? OK, yes. So, in fact, Neanderthals and us are relatively late in the whole story of human evolution. So we think human evolution stretched back at least seven million years. And we in the neanderthals are part of the last few hundred thousand years of that story so we in the neanderthals are relative latecomers and the neanderthal story really begins in the 1850s with the discovery in the neander|||是的，但那是一个开端，我当时做梦也没想到自己最终会把这个作为终身职业。所以，克里斯，对于那些对这个领域一无所知的人来说，我们在谈论尼安德特人时，具体是在哪个时期？他们生活在什么时候？又是什么样的存在？好的，没问题。事实上，尼安德特人和我们在整个人类演化史中都属于比较晚近的阶段。我们认为人类演化史可以追溯到至少七百万年前。而我们和尼安德特人只是这段历史中最后几十万年的一部分，所以我们和尼安德特人都是相对的后来者。尼安德特人的故事实际上始于19世纪50年代，当时在尼安德
valley of a skeleton a human skeleton that gave its name to the group, Neander Valley, Neanderthal. So that's a German. That's right. He was a German. He was found in Germany near Düsseldorf in a valley. It was actually found during quarrying, and it was lucky in a way. It was recovered at all. I mean, the workers threw a lot of the bones out of a cave,
valley of a skeleton a human skeleton that gave its name to the group, Neander Valley, Neanderthal. So that's a German. That's right. He was a German. He was found in Germany near Düsseldorf in a valley. It was actually found during quarrying, and it was lucky in a way. It was recovered at all. I mean, the workers threw a lot of the bones out of a cave,|||谷发现了一具骨骼——一具人类骨骼，这个群体也因此得名：尼安德谷（Neander Valley），尼安德特人（Neanderthal）。所以这是一个德国人？没错。他是一个德国人。他是在德国杜塞尔多夫附近的一个山谷里被发现的。实际上，它是在采石过程中被发现的，从某种意义上说，这些骨骼能被完整保存下来可以说是非常幸运的。我的意思是，工人们把洞穴里的很多骨头都扔了出去，
and luckily they were spotted and identified as a strange as human but a different kind of human and in 1864 William King then working in Galway in Ireland he he named this a new species of human Homo Neanderthalensis and in fact there had been two Neanderthal finds before that that had not been recognized up to then. So in 1830, a Neanderthal child skull had been found at Ongis in Belgium. And that took another hundred years to be recognized as Neanderthal. And a skull had been found in Gibraltar in 1848, blasted out of Forbes Quarry. And that sat on a museum shelf in gibraltar for many years
and luckily they were spotted and identified as a strange as human but a different kind of human and in 1864 William King then working in Galway in Ireland he he named this a new species of human Homo Neanderthalensis and in fact there had been two Neanderthal finds before that that had not been recognized up to then. So in 1830, a Neanderthal child skull had been found at Ongis in Belgium. And that took another hundred years to be recognized as Neanderthal. And a skull had been found in Gibraltar in 1848, blasted out of Forbes Quarry. And that sat on a museum shelf in gibraltar for many years|||幸运的是，它们被认了出来，并被识别为一种奇怪的人类，但属于不同类型的人类。1864年，当时在爱尔兰戈尔韦工作的威廉·金（William King）将这种人类命名为一个新物种：尼安德特人（Homo Neanderthalensis）。事实上，在此之前还有过两次尼安德特人的发现，但在当时并没有被认出来。1830年，在比利时的昂日（Engis）发现了一个尼安德特儿童头骨。这花了整整一百年才被确认属于尼安德特人。1848年，在直布罗陀的福布斯采石场（Forbes' Quarry）通过爆破也发现了一个头骨。这个头骨在直布罗陀的一家博物馆书架上放置了多年
so it was the neander valley find that that kind of got the glory and gave its name to the group oh but so gibraltar so actually it's british well you could yes you could make that claim or belgium or belgium yes yes yeah am i right that the the name is is kind of given and announced in 1859, which is the same year as The Origin of Species is published? Well, there were descriptions of the skeleton before that. But we know that the Gibraltar skull actually was seen by Charles Darwin. Oh, was it? After he'd written Origin of Species, but he was shown the skull a couple of years later the gibraltar skull and of course darwin was aware of the the find from the neander valley and it was the the naming in 1864 that obviously started this debate about who these people were yeah were there different
so it was the neander valley find that that kind of got the glory and gave its name to the group oh but so gibraltar so actually it's british well you could yes you could make that claim or belgium or belgium yes yes yeah am i right that the the name is is kind of given and announced in 1859, which is the same year as The Origin of Species is published? Well, there were descriptions of the skeleton before that. But we know that the Gibraltar skull actually was seen by Charles Darwin. Oh, was it? After he'd written Origin of Species, but he was shown the skull a couple of years later the gibraltar skull and of course darwin was aware of the the find from the neander valley and it was the the naming in 1864 that obviously started this debate about who these people were yeah were there different|||所以是尼安德谷的发现赢得了这份荣耀，并为这个群体命名。哦，不过既然是在直布罗陀发现的，那实际上它算是英国的？嗯，你可以——是的，你可以这么说，或者说是比利时的？比利时也是，是的，没错。我是不是没记错的话，这个名字是在1859年被赋予并公布的？这与《物种起源》出版是同一年吧？嗯，在此之前对这具骨骼有过描述。但我们知道，直布罗陀的那个头骨实际上被查尔斯·达尔文看到过。哦，是吗？那是在他写完《物种起源》之后，不过几年后有人把那个头骨拿给查尔斯·达尔文看——也就是直布罗陀的头骨。当然，达尔文也知道尼安德谷的发现。正是1864年的命名，显然引发了关于“这些人究竟是谁”的争论。是的，究竟有没有不同的
species were they some kind of a version of modern humans so there was a debate straight away some people even thought the remains from Neander Valley were pathological, that this was some sort of diseased modern human. It's a Cossack, wasn't it? That's right. There was a very extreme view that this was some Cossack soldier, a horseman, and he'd been wounded in battle and he crawled into a cave in Germany and he died there.
species were they some kind of a version of modern humans so there was a debate straight away some people even thought the remains from Neander Valley were pathological, that this was some sort of diseased modern human. It's a Cossack, wasn't it? That's right. There was a very extreme view that this was some Cossack soldier, a horseman, and he'd been wounded in battle and he crawled into a cave in Germany and he died there.|||物种？他们是现代人类的某种变体吗？因此，争论随即爆发。甚至有人认为尼安德谷的遗骸有病理问题，认为这是一种患病的现代人类。是个哥萨克人，对吧？没错。当时有一种非常极端的观点，认为这是一个哥萨克士兵、一个骑兵，他在战斗中受伤，然后爬进了德国的一个山洞并在那里死去。
And the agony of his pain in the last few days led to these brow ridges developing on his on his head all right so after that after the napoleonic wars or something that's right yes that's right so he would be a victim of a cossack from the napoleonic wars um so yes there was some pretty extreme views around and gradually it was recognized that you know the neanderthal huuxley recognised that the Neander Valley skeleton, the skull cap, had a big brain as big as a modern human. So that was recognised early on. But of course, the bones of the skeleton were slightly differently shaped from our own. And there was this big brow ridge over the eyes, which was obviously quite distinctive.
And the agony of his pain in the last few days led to these brow ridges developing on his on his head all right so after that after the napoleonic wars or something that's right yes that's right so he would be a victim of a cossack from the napoleonic wars um so yes there was some pretty extreme views around and gradually it was recognized that you know the neanderthal huuxley recognised that the Neander Valley skeleton, the skull cap, had a big brain as big as a modern human. So that was recognised early on. But of course, the bones of the skeleton were slightly differently shaped from our own. And there was this big brow ridge over the eyes, which was obviously quite distinctive.|||他在最后几天经受的痛苦折磨导致他的头部发育出了这些眉脊——好吧，所以这是在拿破仑战争之后什么的？没错，是的，完全正确。所以他会被认为是拿破仑战争中的一名哥萨克受害者。嗯，所以当时确实存在一些相当极端的观点。但渐渐地，人们认识到——你知道，尼安德特人……赫胥黎（Huxley）认识到尼安德谷骨骼的头盖骨拥有一个和现代人一样大的大脑。这一点很早就被认识到了。但当然，这具骨骼的骨头形状与我们自己的略有不同，而且眼睛上方有一个巨大的眉脊，这显然非常独特。
So before this, Chris, did people have any conception that there would have been human relatives, as it were or was this an absolute kind of bolt from the blue uh it was a bolt from it was the first ancient kind of human recognized so fossil human skeletons had been found earlier so there was one from paviland cave uh in in wales found in the 1820s but that was a modern human so although it was there was debate about it being prehistoric, in fact, the general view was that it might be even just a Roman age skeleton and not very ancient.
So before this, Chris, did people have any conception that there would have been human relatives, as it were or was this an absolute kind of bolt from the blue uh it was a bolt from it was the first ancient kind of human recognized so fossil human skeletons had been found earlier so there was one from paviland cave uh in in wales found in the 1820s but that was a modern human so although it was there was debate about it being prehistoric, in fact, the general view was that it might be even just a Roman age skeleton and not very ancient.|||所以在这次发现之前，克里斯，人们是否有过“存在人类近亲”之类的概念？还是说这完全是一个晴天霹雳式的突发事件？嗯，这确实是个晴天霹雳，这是人们认识的第一种古代人类。在此之前其实也发现过化石人类骨骼，比如1820年代在威尔士帕维兰洞穴（Paviland Cave）发现的一具骨骼，但那是一个现代人。所以尽管当时关于它是否属于史前时期有过争论，但普遍的观点其实认为它可能只是一具罗马时期的骨骼，并没有那么古老。
So people had very little conception of how deep human history would end up going. There were still, of course, some people working on biblical timescales of just a few thousand years for the whole story. But, of course, geologists like Charles Lyell were arguing that actually, people working on biblical time scales of just a few thousand years for the whole story but of course geologists like charles lyle were arguing that actually you know the earth history went back millions of years and so some people did speculate that humans could go back a long way but it was the neanderthal neanderthal skeleton that really started this debate about ancient humans that were potentially different from us chris the in The Origin of Species, Darwin
So people had very little conception of how deep human history would end up going. There were still, of course, some people working on biblical timescales of just a few thousand years for the whole story. But, of course, geologists like Charles Lyell were arguing that actually, people working on biblical time scales of just a few thousand years for the whole story but of course geologists like charles lyle were arguing that actually you know the earth history went back millions of years and so some people did speculate that humans could go back a long way but it was the neanderthal neanderthal skeleton that really started this debate about ancient humans that were potentially different from us chris the in The Origin of Species, Darwin|||因此，人们对人类历史究竟能追溯到多么久远几乎没有什么概念。当然，当时仍有一些人按照《圣经》的时间尺度，认为整个人类历史只有短短几千年。但当然，像查尔斯·莱尔（Charles Lyell）这样的地质学家则在争论说——事实上，虽然有人坚守《圣经》中那短短几千年的整体历史时间尺度，但像查尔斯·莱尔这样的地质学家却在争论说，地球的历史其实可以追溯到数百万年前。因此，确实有些人推测人类的历史可以追溯到很久远的过去，但正是尼安德特人的骨骼真正引发了关于“与我们潜在不同的古代人类”的这场争论。克里斯，在《物种起源》中，达尔文
famously does not talk about human evolution. And he does then go on in The Tent of Man to talk about it. How unsettling is the discovery of Neanderthals to human conceptions of themselves? And how does it kind of feed through into i don't know kind of ideas of um scientific racism hierarchy of races and things like that that really kind of takes off after after the origin of species yeah so of course it it does get drawn into that debate so so huxley recognizing that this was large brained he in a sense saw the neander valley skeleton or the skull in particular as being one end of a long chain of humans that was you know neanderthal with very large brow ridges at the other at one end and then moving through you know some more recent human finds and there were more recent human finds that had bigger brow ridges than others so for huxley this was one end of a long
famously does not talk about human evolution. And he does then go on in The Tent of Man to talk about it. How unsettling is the discovery of Neanderthals to human conceptions of themselves? And how does it kind of feed through into i don't know kind of ideas of um scientific racism hierarchy of races and things like that that really kind of takes off after after the origin of species yeah so o course it it does get drawn into that debate so so huxley recognizing that this was large brained he in a sense saw the neander valley skeleton or the skull in particular as being one end of a long chain of humans that was you know neanderthal with very large brow ridges at the other at one end and then moving through you know some more recent human finds and there were more recent human finds that had bigger brow ridges than others so for huxley this was one end of a long|||众所周知并没有谈论人类的演化。而他随后在《人类的由来》（The Descent of Man）中才开始探讨这个问题。尼安德特人的发现对人类自我认知的冲击有多大？它又是如何演变成——我不知道，比如科学种族主义、种族等级制度等思想——这些思想在《物种起源》出版之后真正大行其道？是的，所以它确实被卷入了那场争论中。赫胥黎认识到这具骨骼拥有大脑，在某种意义上，他将尼安德谷的骨骼、特别是那个头骨，视为人类漫长演化链条的一端：另一端是拥有巨大眉脊的尼安德特人，然后通过一些更近时期的人类发现过渡过来（有些更近时期发现的人类头骨甚至比其他头骨拥有更大的眉脊）。因此，在赫胥黎看来，这是漫长
chain of of humanity so i suppose you know he would have argued it could even be an extreme form of homo sapiens their own species but then there were other people as i say who named it as a distinct species william king described you know really quite a lot of very primitive and you could say bestial features on this Neanderthal. So straight away, there was a debate there about was this just a different kind of modern human or could it be something really different? And with the ideas of evolution, much more primitive. And by the time we get to the 1900s, of course, no really ancient fossils have been found in places like Africa. So the African fossil discoveries that we know about now, those only started to appear in the 1920s.
chain of of humanity so i suppose you know he would have argued it could even be an extreme form of homo sapiens their own species but then there were other people as i say who named it as a distinct species william king described you know really quite a lot of very primitive and you could say bestial features on this Neanderthal. So straight away, there was a debate there about was this just a different kind of modern human or could it be something really different? And with the ideas of evolution, much more primitive. And by the time we get to the 1900s, of course, no really ancient fossils have been found in places like Africa. So the African fossil discoveries that we know about now, those only started to appear in the 1920s.|||人类链条的一端。所以我想，你知道，他可能会认为这甚至可能是智人（他们自己的物种）的一种极端形式。但正如我所说，还有其他人将其命名为一个截然不同的物种。威廉·金描述了尼安德特人身上非常多原始的、甚至可以说是野兽般的特征。因此，这立刻引发了一场争论：这究竟只是另一种不同的现代人，还是一种截然不同的存在？而且结合演化的观点，它要原始得多。到了20世纪1900年代时，当然，在非洲等地还没有发现真正极其古老的化石。所以我们现在所知的非洲化石发现，直到20世纪20年代才开始出现。
So in the early 1900s, people were looking for kind of so-called missing links. Yeah. And there had been a find in Java that we now know is a Homo erectus. And that was really quite ape-like. And the Neanderthals were also in that debate. And some of the reconstructions of Neanderthals made them very ape-like. They were depicted as being bent-kneed, grasping big toes, very hairy, head hung forward, not walking fully erect.
So in the early 1900s, people were looking for kind of so-called missing links. Yeah. And there had been a find in Java that we now know is a Homo erectus. And that was really quite ape-like. And the Neanderthals were also in that debate. And some of the reconstructions of Neanderthals made them very ape-like. They were depicted as being bent-kneed, grasping big toes, very hairy, head hung forward, not walking fully erect.|||所以在20世纪初，人们在寻找所谓的“缺失环节”（missing links）。是的。当时在爪哇岛有一个发现，我们现在知道那是直立人（Homo erectus）。那个发现非常像猿。尼安德特人也被卷入了那场争论中。对尼安德特人的一些复原图让他们看起来非常像猿。他们被描绘成膝盖微弯、大脚趾具有抓握能力、全身多毛、头部向前耷拉、无法完全直立行走的样子。
So there was that debate going on about them being really an ape-like form of human, a sort of missing link. Whereas, you know, now, of course, the debate about Neanderthals has moved on. I think it's much more difficult to say the Neanderthals were even culturally inferior to modern humans who were around at the same time. So the behavioral gap between between the antiles and us is narrowed. Some people would say it's disappeared. And I think there is this risk of, you know, getting them into this debate about inferiority and superiority. And it's part of this misconception that, you know, all these human forms were evolving towards us,
So there was that debate going on about them being really an ape-like form of human, a sort of missing link. Whereas, you know, now, of course, the debate about Neanderthals has moved on. I think it's much more difficult to say the Neanderthals were even culturally inferior to modern humans who were around at the same time. So the behavioral gap between between the antiles and us is narrowed. Some people would say it's disappeared. And I think there is this risk of, you know, getting them into this debate about inferiority and superiority. And it's part of this misconception that, you know, all these human forms were evolving towards us,|||因此当时存在这样一种争论：他们究竟是一种类猿的人类形态，还是某种缺失的环节。然而，你知道，现在关于尼安德特人的讨论当然已经翻开了新的一页。我认为现在很难再宣称尼安德特人在文化上比同时代的现代人低等了。因此，尼安德特人与我们之间的行为差距已经缩小了。有些人甚至会说这种差距已经消失了。而且我认为这里存在一种风险，就是把他们卷入这种关于劣等与优等的争论中，这也是一种误解的一部分，即认为所有这些人类形态都在朝着我们的方向演化，
that we were some kind of perfection of humanity and everything was evolving to be like us. And if they evolved to be like us, they were successful. And if they didn't evolve to be like us, they were unsuccessful. So there is that debate as well. And, yes, it does link into this idea of superiority, modernity. The fact that we're so numerous around the world and apparently so successful means that some people see us as the kind of
that we were some kind of perfection of humanity and everything was evolving to be like us. And if they evolved to be like us, they were successful. And if they didn't evolve to be like us, they were unsuccessful. So there is that debate as well. And, yes, it does link into this idea of superiority, modernity. The fact that we're so numerous around the world and apparently so successful means that some people see us as the kind of|||认为我们是人类某种完美形态，世间万物都在演化得像我们一样。如果他们演化得像我们一样，他们就是成功的；如果没有演化得像我们一样，他们就是不成功的。所以也存在这样一场争论。是的，这确实与优越性、现代性的观念联系在一起。我们在世界各地人口众多、显然非常成功，这意味着有些人将我们视作
height of evolution uh whereas you know i'm a paleontologist in a paleontology department and i you know i see us as just another form of animal in a sense we're very successful in numbers but whether we're successful in the long term we're newcomers in evolution could you not then though say that we we clearly were more successful than Neanderthals, as evidenced by the fact that there are an awful lot of us and there are none of them? I mean, would that be too simplistic a way of putting it? Well, it's one way of measuring success. But if you were measuring success in terms of numbers, then things like bacteria or other forms of life would be more successful than us.
height of evolution uh whereas you know i'm a paleontologist in a paleontology department and i you know i see us as just another form of animal in a sense we're very successful in numbers but whether we're successful in the long term we're newcomers in evolution could you not then though say that we we clearly were more successful than Neanderthals, as evidenced by the fact that there are an awful lot of us and there are none of them? I mean, would that be too simplistic a way of putting it? Well, it's one way of measuring success. But if you were measuring success in terms of numbers, then things like bacteria or other forms of life would be more successful than us.|||演化的巅峰。然而，你知道，我是古生物学系的一名古生物学家，在我看来，我们其实只是另一种形式的动物。从某种意义上说，我们在数量上非常成功，但至于我们在长期来看是否成功——我们在演化中其实只是后来者。难道你就不能说，我们显然比尼安德特人更成功吗？证据就是我们有如此庞大的人数，而他们已经不复存在了。我的意思是，这种说法会不会太简单化了？嗯，这是衡量成功的一种方式。但如果你用数量来衡量成功，那么像细菌或其他生命形式会比我们更成功。
Right. And obviously, you know, if we look at the way our planet is and the health of our planet at the moment, you could see that our success might seem great, but, you know, how successful we will look in a few thousand years is another story. So in geological time, as I say, we in the Neanderthals are newcomers to the story.
Right. And obviously, you know, if we look at the way our planet is and the health of our planet at the moment, you could see that our success might seem great, but, you know, how successful we will look in a few thousand years is another story. So in geological time, as I say, we in the Neanderthals are newcomers to the story.|||对吧？显而易见，如果你看看我们星球的现状以及目前地球的健康状况，你就会发现我们的成功可能看起来很伟大，但是，你知道，再过几千年我们看起来是否还算成功，那就是另一回事了。所以在地质时间尺度上，正如我所说，我们和尼安德特人都是这场故事中的后来者。
And I think, you know, Homo erectus, on conventional views, that species of human, lasted for at least one and a half million years. So we've got a long way to go to match that in terms of longevity. So I think it depends what you measure by success. Is it just about numbers? It's also about your effect on the environment environment how successful you are in the long term and i think there's you know there's certainly doubts about how successful we're going to be in the long term as a species well so chris picking up on that um one of the reasons why i um i quoted uh becky ragsikes's wonderful book with that thing neanderthals first kindled history so this is a history podcast does
And I think, you know, Homo erectus, on conventional views, that species of human, lasted for at least one and a half million years. So we've got a long way to go to match that in terms of longevity. So I think it depends what you measure by success. Is it just about numbers? It's also about your effect on the environment environment how successful you are in the long term and i think there's you know there's certainly doubts about how successful we're going to be in the long term as a species well so chris picking up on that um one of the reasons why i um i quoted uh becky ragsikes's wonderful book with that thing neanderthals first kindled history so this is a history podcast does|||而且我认为，按照传统观点，直立人这一人类物种至少持续了一百五十万年。所以我们在延续时间（寿数）上要达到这个标准，还有很长的路要走。因此我认为这取决于你如何定义成功。成功仅仅关乎数量吗？它还关乎你对环境的影响、你长期的成功程度。而且我认为，对于我们作为一个物种在长期来看是否能取得成功，人们无疑是存在疑虑的。那么，克里斯，顺着这个话题，我引用贝基·拉格·赛克斯那本精彩的书——“尼安德特人最早点燃了历史之火”——原因之一是，这是一档历史播客，
it make sense to think of Neanderthals as offering us as Homo sapiens a kind of an alternative sense of how history might have evolved because you're basically saying that Neanderthals and Homo sapiens constitute kind of two divergent ways of being human and if we if we have history and it's made up of how we interact with one another how we interact with the environment how we've kind of developed a culture over the course of the millennia can we say the same about Neanderthals did Neanderthals also construct something that we would recognise as a kind of historical culture, perhaps? I think it depends how you define history and culture. I think that obviously these people were surviving at the time with a culture. They had a whole suite
it make sense to think of Neanderthals as offering us as Homo sapiens a kind of an alternative sense of how history might have evolved because you're basically saying that Neanderthals and Homo sapiens constitute kind of two divergent ways of being human and if we if we have history and it's made up of how we interact with one another how we interact with the environment how we've kind of developed a culture over the course of the millennia can we say the same about Neanderthals did Neanderthals also construct something that we would recognise as a kind of historical culture, perhaps? I think it depends how you define history and culture. I think that obviously these people were surviving at the time with a culture. They had a whole suite|||把尼安德特人视为为我们智人提供了一种关于历史可能如何演化的“替代性视角”，这有意义吗？因为你基本上是在说，尼安德特人和智人构成了做人的两种分化的方式。如果我们拥有历史，而历史是由我们如何相互交往、如何与环境互动、以及我们在几千年的历程中如何发展出文化所构成的，我们能对尼安德特人作同样的评价吗？尼安德特人是否也构建了某种我们或许可以认同的历史文化？我认为这取决于你如何定义历史和文化。我认为当时这些人显然是带着某种文化在生存的。他们拥有整套
of features and behaviours that they passed on through time. So in a sense, they were creating history in that way. They probably did tell stories and pass them down. They probably had language. Modern humans did too. And it's not just about even us and Neanderthals, because we know there was another kind of human over in East Asia called the Denisovans. And they're a third kind of human. And in fact, looking more widely, in the last 100,000 years, there were at least five kinds of humans around on the earth. So it's not even just us and Neanderthals. There were all these different experiments in how to be a human. We're the one that survived. The others disappeared.
of features and behaviours that they passed on through time. So in a sense, they were creating history in that way. They probably did tell stories and pass them down. They probably had language. Modern humans did too. And it's not just about even us and Neanderthals, because we know there was another kind of human over in East Asia called the Denisovans. And they're a third kind of human. And in fact, looking more widely, in the last 100,000 years, there were at least five kinds of humans around on the earth. So it's not even just us and Neanderthals. There were all these different experiments in how to be a human. We're the one that survived. The others disappeared.|||特征和行为，并在时间的长河中将它们传承了下来。所以从某种意义上说，他们正是通过这种方式在创造历史。他们很可能也讲述并代代相传着故事。他们可能拥有语言。现代人类也是如此。而且这不仅仅关乎我们和尼安德特人，因为我们知道在东亚还有另一种被称为杰尼索瓦人（Denisovans）的人类。他们是第三种人类。事实上，放宽视野来看，在过去的十万年里，地球上曾同时存在过至少五种不同的人类。所以这甚至不仅仅是我们和尼安德特人。曾经存在过所有这些关于“如何成为人类”的不同实验。而我们是唯一幸存下来的那个，其他的都消失了。
And obviously, one of the big questions is, why are we the only ones left of all these experiments to be human? As a complete outsider, can I ask a quick definitional question? So we and Neanderthals and Denisovans, for example, are all human. But what is a human? Is it just a particular kind of ape or what is the definition? Yeah, that's a good question. And there isn't agreement on experts. So for me, the genus Homo, so we're homo sapiens the neanderthals i call them
And obviously, one of the big questions is, why are we the only ones left of all these experiments to be human? As a complete outsider, can I ask a quick definitional question? So we and Neanderthals and Denisovans, for example, are all human. But what is a human? Is it just a particular kind of ape or what is the definition? Yeah, that's a good question. And there isn't agreement on experts. So for me, the genus Homo, so we're homo sapiens the neanderthals i call them|||显而易见，最大的问题之一就是：在所有这些成为人类的实验中，为什么只剩下了我们？作为一个彻头彻尾的外行，我可以问一个关于定义的小问题吗？比如我们、尼安德特人和杰尼索瓦人都是人类。但究竟什么才是人类？它只是一种特定类型的猿，还是有什么别的定义？是的，这是一个好问题。专家们对此并没有达成共识。对我而言，“人属”（Homo）——我们是智人（Homo sapiens），尼安德特人我称他们为
homo neanderthalensis um membership of the genus homo for me is what it is is what is being human and being in that genus uh the representatives have larger brains they have a human-shaped body they have technology um and and so on so there are certain features in the skeleton that we can pick up in fossils to determine whether something's human or not. Now, for some people, human is a term they would only apply to Homo sapiens, our own species. I find that a bit worrying because it means Neanderthals aren't human. And as we're going to come on to discuss, no doubt, we have interbred with the Neanderthals and with the Denisovans. So in a sense, that means we, as humans, we interbred with non-humans. I think that's really pushing the arguments in a strange direction.
homo neanderthalensis um membership of the genus homo for me is what it is is what is being human and being in that genus uh the representatives have larger brains they have a human-shaped body they have technology um and and so on so there are certain features in the skeleton that we can pick up in fossils to determine whether something's human or not. Now, for some people, human is a term they would only apply to Homo sapiens, our own species. I find that a bit worrying because it means Neanderthals aren't human. And as we're going to come on to discuss, no doubt, we have interbred with the Neanderthals and with the Denisovans. So in a sense, that means we, as humans, we interbred with non-humans. I think that's really pushing the arguments in a strange direction.|||尼安德特人（Homo neanderthalensis）——在我看来，成为人属的成员就是“人”，属于这个属就意味着是人类。这个属的代表拥有更大的大脑，拥有人类形状的身体，拥有技术等等。因此，我们可以在化石的骨骼中捕捉到某些特征，以此来判断某个生物是否属于人类。然而，对某些人来说，“人类”这个词他们只应用于智人，也就是我们自己的物种。我觉得这有点令人担忧，因为这意味着尼安德特人不是人。正如我们接下来要讨论的毫无疑问的那样，我们曾与尼安德特人和杰尼索瓦人发生过基因交流（杂交）。所以从某种意义上说，这意味着我们作为人类，竟然与“非人”交配了。我认为这确实把论点推向了一个奇怪的方向。
So for me, membership of the genus Homo means human. So yes, we Neanderthals are homo so we are human so I'm I just see them as you say as another model of human another way to be human in a sense we've maybe we got lucky that could be why we're here and they're not we just got lucky certain things happen in our prehistory that helped us survive and that and in the Neanderthals case things turned against them but we should bear in mind with all of this that they're not completely gone yeah of course we'll come on to this but yes they're physically extinct uh and may have gone extinct around 40 000 years
So for me, membership of the genus Homo means human. So yes, we Neanderthals are homo so we are human so I'm I just see them as you say as another model of human another way to be human in a sense we've maybe we got lucky that could be why we're here and they're not we just got lucky certain things happen in our prehistory that helped us survive and that and in the Neanderthals case things turned against them but we should bear in mind with all of this that they're not completely gone yeah of course we'll come on to this but yes they're physically extinct uh and may have gone extinct around 40 000 years|||所以对我和言，人属的成员资格就意味着人类。所以是的，我们和尼安德特人都是人属，所以我们都是人类。因此我只是把他们——正如你所说——看作人类的另一种模版、做人的另一种方式。从某种意义上说，也许是我们比较幸运，这可能就是为什么我们留在这里而他们不在了。我们只是比较幸运，我们的史前时期发生了一些事情帮助我们生存了下来；而在尼安德特人的情况下，事情对他们不利。但我们在所有这些讨论中都应该记住，他们并没有完全消失。是的，当然，我们接下来会谈到这一点，但确实他们在物理上已经灭绝了，并且大约在四万年前就可能已经灭绝了
ago physically but they live on in our in our dna so you know each of us now in this podcast have Neanderthal DNA around the level of probably 2%. So, you know, we've all got a bit of Neanderthal in our DNA. And that's true for the majority of people in the world today. So the Neanderthals have not disappeared completely. And neither have the Denisovans. Their DNA lives on in billions of people today as well. The way that Neanderthals have been understood since they were first discovered. So as you said, to begin with,
ago physically but they live on in our in our dna so you know each of us now in this podcast have Neanderthal DNA around the level of probably 2%. So, you know, we've all got a bit of Neanderthal in our DNA. And that is true for the majority of people in the world today. So the Neanderthals have not disappeared completely. And neither have the Denisovans. Their DNA lives on in billions of people today as well. The way that Neanderthals have been understood since they were first discovered. So as you said, to begin with,|||虽然在肉体上消失了，但他们依然活在我们的DNA中。所以你知道，我们现在参加这个播客的每个人，体内都有大约2%左右的尼安德特人DNA。所以，你知道，我们所有人的DNA里都有那么一点尼安德特人的成分。对于当今世界上绝大多数人来说也是如此。因此，尼安德特人并没有完全消失。杰尼索瓦人也没有。他们的DNA至今仍然活在数十亿人的体内。自从尼安德特人被首次发现以来，人们对他们的理解方式一直在变化。正如你所说，一开始时，
they're kind of cast as savage, brutish, ape-like. And then, am I right that, I mean, for instance, in William Golding's book that Dominic mentioned, The Inheritors, the Inheritors are Homo sapiens. And we see the world through Neanderthal eyes. And I mean, I'm guessing, I don't know enough about about the book actually but i'm guessing that it's kind of influenced by um decolonization the idea that uh kind of anxiety about western colonialism perhaps well it's golding's sense of human evil tom that's what it is it's kind of yeah humans are
they're kind of cast as savage, brutish, ape-like. And then, am I right that, I mean, for instance, in William Golding's book that Dominic mentioned, The Inheritors, the Inheritors are Homo sapiens. And we see the world through Neanderthal eyes. And I mean, I'm guessing, I don't know enough about about the book actually but i'm guessing that it's kind of influenced by um decolonization the idea that uh kind of anxiety about western colonialism perhaps well it's golding's sense of human evil tom that's what it is it's kind of yeah humans are|||他们被刻画成野蛮、粗鲁、像猿一样的形象。然后，我是不是没记错的话——我的意思是，比如在多米尼克提到威廉·金的那本书《继承者》中，继承者其实是智人。而我们是通过尼安德特人的眼睛来看待这个世界的。我的意思是，我猜——其实我对这本书了解不够深入——但我猜它可能受到了去殖民化运动的影响，或者是对西方殖民主义某种焦虑的体现？嗯，汤姆，那是戈尔丁对人类之恶的一种感知，事实就是这样，这有点像是——是的，人类是
cruel and corrupt and and they get a lot are the flies and things. Yeah, absolutely. And then, Chris, am I right that in the 60s, at a site in Kurdistan in northern Iraq called Shanidar, which is one of the great sites for Neanderthal archaeology, a body was found, a Neanderthal body was found that seemed to be a grave and it was thought to be a grave because there appeared to have been flower wreaths laid there. And I gather that this is no longer thought to have a grave because there appeared to have been flower wreaths laid there and i gather that this is no longer thought to have been the case but in the 60s you know the age of flower power this kind of gave an image of neanderthals not as brutish and thuggish but kind of peace
cruel and corrupt and and they get a lot are the flies and things. Yeah, absolutely. And then, Chris, am I right that in the 60s, at a site in Kurdistan in northern Iraq called Shanidar, which is one of the great sites for Neanderthal archaeology, a body was found, a Neanderthal body was found that seemed to be a grave and it was thought to be a grave because there appeared to have been flower wreaths laid there. And I gather that this is no longer thought to have a grave because there appeared to have been flower wreaths laid there and i gather that this is no longer thought to have been the case but in the 60s you know the age of flower power this kind of gave an image of neanderthals not as brutish and thuggish but kind of peace|||残酷且腐化的，他们会经历像《蝇王》里那样的东西。是的，完全如此。然后，克里斯，我是不是没记错的话，在20世纪60年代，在伊拉克北部库尔德斯坦一个名叫沙尼达尔（Shanidar）的遗址——那是尼安德特人考古学中最重要的遗址之一——发现了一具遗体，一具尼安德特人的遗体，它看起来像是一个墓葬。之所以被认为是一个墓葬，是因为那里似乎摆放过花环。据我所知，现在人们已经不再认为那是——是因为那里似乎摆放过花环而被当成墓葬，据我了解，现在人们已经不再这样认为了。但在20世纪60年代，你知道，那是“花之力量”（flower power）的时代，这给尼安德特人塑造了一种形象：他们不再是粗鲁暴戾的暴徒，而是一种爱好和平的、
loving wiped out by the sinister intrusion of of homo sapiens and and now have we moved on from that to a position where we're saying that you know what what were the relations between homo sapiens and and neanderthals presumably if they're interbreeding it's not either that one is preying on the other necessarily but they might have kind of interacted yes i mean if we can come back if you can come back to that particular question and i'm going to go back in time about this whole question of the image of the Neanderthals first. So yes, a reconstruction was made of a Neanderthal skeleton from France, from La Chapelle. And this reconstruction really emphasized the distinctiveness of the Neanderthals. And it was very influential. But the debate about the nature of the Neanderthals does go way back. So there was always this debate about how human they were,
loving wiped out by the sinister intrusion of of homo sapiens and and now have we moved on from that to a position where we're saying that you know what what were the relations between homo sapiens and and neanderthals presumably if they're interbreeding it's not either that one is preying on the other necessarily but they might have kind of interacted yes i mean if we can come back if you can come back to that particular question and i'm going to go back in time about this whole question of the image of the Neanderthals first. So yes, a reconstruction was made of a Neanderthal skeleton from France, from La Chapelle. And this reconstruction really emphasized the distinctiveness of the Neanderthals. And it was very influential. But the debate about the nature of the Neanderthals does go way back. So there was always this debate about how human they were,|||被智人险恶入侵所消灭的群体。那么现在，我们是否已经从那种观点转变到了这样一种立场：我们认为智人与尼安德特人之间的关系究竟是怎样的？如果他们发生了基因交流，那么这并不一定意味着其中一方在捕食另一方，而是他们可能进行过某种形式的互动。是的，如果我们可以回到那个特定的问题——首先我要把时间倒回，先谈谈尼安德特人形象的整个演变过程。所以是的，人们曾对在法国拉沙佩勒（La Chapelle）发现的一具尼安德特人骨骼进行了复原。这个复原模型极大地强调了尼安德特人的独特性，并且产生了非常深远的影响。但关于尼安德特人本质的争论其实由来已久。所以一直以来都存在这样一场争论：他们究竟有多像人类，
how like us they were. And the pendulum has swung backwards and forwards on this question. So after that reconstruction of the La Chapelle Neanderthal, we find H.G. Wells writing a story called The Grizzly Folk, where he really does paint the Neanderthals as being very distinct and very, you know, a sort of dark side, if you like, of humanity. Warlocks. Yes, like the warlocks.
how like us they were. And the pendulum has swung backwards and forwards on this question. So after that reconstruction of the La Chapelle Neanderthal, we find H.G. Wells writing a story called The Grizzly Folk, where he really does paint the Neanderthals as being very distinct and very, you know, a sort of dark side, if you like, of humanity. Warlocks. Yes, like the warlocks.|||他们有多像我们。在这个问题上，天平一直摆来摆去。所以在拉沙佩勒的尼安德特人复原之后，我们看到H.G.威尔斯（H.G. Wells）写了一篇名为《灰熊人》（The Grizzly Folk）的故事，他在书中确实把尼安德特人描绘得非常独特，而且——你知道的——如果你愿意的话，简直就是人类阴暗面的一种写照。巫师。是的，就像巫师一样。
It's that sort of image almost. And Goldings is a reaction against that. So the Inheritors paints them as like children of nature, relatively innocent in a way. And it's, as you say, it's the modern humans are the bad guys. And of course, that was, you know, if we look at Lord of the Flies, you know, we've got that dual nature of humanity showing up, you know, humanity as being potentially cruel.
It's that sort of image almost. And Goldings is a reaction against that. So the Inheritors paints them as like children of nature, relatively innocent in a way. And it's, as you say, it's the modern humans are the bad guys. And of course, that was, you know, if we look at Lord of the Flies, you know, we've got that dual nature of humanity showing up, you know, humanity as being potentially cruel.|||几乎就是那种形象。而戈尔丁的作品则是对这种形象的一种反拨。所以《继承者》将他们描绘得如同大自然的儿童，在某种程度上相对天真无邪。而且正如你所说，现代人成了坏蛋。当然，你知道，如果我们看看《蝇王》，就会发现人类身上展现出了那种双重本性——人类可能具有残酷的一面。
And so the way the modern humans treat the Neanderthals is cruel. You know, it's a sort of genocide almost, you could say. So, yes, Golding is looking at those issues. It's the other side of the mirror. And as you say, they're moving on to the 1960s with Shanidar. Yes, Ralph Selecki, who led the excavations at Shanidar, wrote a book called Neanderthals, the First Flower Children, I think it was called, or the First Flower,
And so the way the modern humans treat the Neanderthals is cruel. You know, it's a sort of genocide almost, you could say. So, yes, Golding is looking at those issues. It's the other side of the mirror. And as you say, they're moving on to the 1960s with Shanidar. Yes, Ralph Selecki, who led the excavations at Shanidar, wrote a book called Neanderthals, the First Flower Children, I think it was called, or the First Flower,|||因此，现代人对待尼安德特人的方式是残酷的。你知道，甚至可以说这是一种类似种族灭绝的行为。所以，是的，戈尔丁正在审视这些问题。那是镜子的另一面。正如你所说，时间来到了20世纪60年代的沙尼达尔。是的，领导沙尼达尔发掘工作的拉尔夫·塞莱基（Ralph Solecki）写了一本书，书名好像叫《尼安德特人：第一代花童》（Neanderthals: The First Flower Children），或者叫“第一朵花”之类的。
very much a book of his time. And, yes, so the pendulum has swung backwards and forwards let's say we go on to the 1990s i think the pendulum had swung away from that image of the neanderthals to make them more distinct you know we had evolved in africa and there must be something about the african environment that gave us superiority maybe we developed cave art and we developed sophisticated tools and that led us to do well in Africa and then come out of Africa and then very quickly replace the Neanderthals. And so that was the view maybe in the 1990s, the predominant view. But then as we get into the
very much a book of his time. And, yes, so the pendulum has swung backwards and forwards let's say we go on to the 1990s i think the pendulum had swung away from that image of the neanderthals to make them more distinct you know we had evolved in africa and there must be something about the african environment that gave us superiority maybe we developed cave art and we developed sophisticated tools and that led us to do well in Africa and then come out of Africa and then very quickly replace the Neanderthals. And so that was the view maybe in the 1990s, the predominant view. But then as we get into the|||这非常符合他那个时代的特征。所以，是的，天平就这样来回摆动。假使我们把时间推到20世纪90年代，我认为当时的天平已经从那种尼安德特人的形象摆开了，转而强调我们的独特性：你知道，我们在非洲演化，非洲的环境中一定有什么东西赋予了我们优越性；也许我们发展出了洞穴艺术，发展出了复杂的工具，这让我们在非洲表现出色，然后走出了非洲，并非常迅速地取代了尼安德特人。所以这可能就是20世纪90年代时的主流观点。但当我们进入
2000s, we start to see the pendulum swing back again as more and more discoveries are made, which show that the Neanderthals were matching modern humans, let's say 100,000 or 200,000 years ago in their complexity of behavior. And those discoveries are still coming through. And so now, as I say, if there is a behavioral gap, it's a very narrow one. And I think probably we should look at the Neanderthals as being very successful in their own right in what they did. And we were successful in our own right in what we did. We shared many behaviors with them, but there were some distinctions. And I think that our survival probably was a matter of luck as well as perhaps being in the right place and the right time with the right little bits of behavior
2000s, we start to see the pendulum swing back again as more and more discoveries are made, which show that the Neanderthals were matching modern humans, let's say 100,000 or 200,000 years ago in their complexity of behavior. And those discoveries are still coming through. And so now, as I say, if there is a behavioral gap, it's a very narrow one. And I think probably we should look at the Neanderthals as being very successful in their own right in what they did. And we were successful in our own right in what we did. We shared many behaviors with them, but there were some distinctions. And I think that our survival probably was a matter of luck as well as perhaps being in the right place and the right time with the right little bits of behavior|||2000年代时，我们开始看到天平再次摆回去了，因为越来越多的发现表明，在10万年或20万年前，尼安德特人在行为复杂性上已经能够与现代人相媲美。而这些发现至今仍在不断涌现。因此正如我所说，如果现在还存在行为差距的话，那也是非常狭小的。我想我们或许应该将尼安德特人视为在其所从事的事情上本身就非常成功的一个群体；而我们在我们所做的事情上也很成功。我们与他们共享了许多行为，但也存在一些区别。我认为我们的生存可能既取决于运气，也可能取决于在正确的时间、正确的地点具备了正确的一些微小行为特征，
that gave us success. And it may have even been down to numbers in the end that the Neanderthals had been living in an environment where there were very severe climate changes happening repeatedly. Every few thousand years, the climate in Europe switched back from nearly as warm as the present day to bitterly cold. These changes happened very rapidly and they happened every few hundred or few thousand years. So I think the Neanderthals were never able to build up their numbers under those circumstances. So their diversity, their numbers were reduced. They had low genetic diversity.
that gave us success. And it may have even been down to numbers in the end that the Neanderthals had been living in an environment where there were very severe climate changes happening repeatedly. Every few thousand years, the climate in Europe switched back from nearly as warm as the present day to bitterly cold. These changes happened very rapidly and they happened every few hundred or few thousand years. So I think the Neanderthals were never able to build up their numbers under those circumstances. So their diversity, their numbers were reduced. They had low genetic diversity.|||从而赋予了我们成功。归根结底，这甚至可能关乎人口数量。尼安德特人一直生活在一个频繁发生极其严重气候变化的环境中。每隔几千年，欧洲的气候就会从几乎像今天一样温暖急剧转变为严寒。这些变化发生得非常迅速，每隔几百年或几千年就会发生一次。所以我认为在这种情况下，尼安德特人永远无法积累起庞大的人口数量。因此，他们的多样性、他们的数量都减少了。他们拥有较低的遗传多样性。
They had low numbers. And so in a sense, maybe they were already a threatened species. And then modern humans came out of Africa about 60,000 years ago, started entering the territory of the Neanderthals. And that may have eventually just destabilized them so much that they just went extinct. Does that mean you could almost draw a map? Tom was talking about history. And, you know, we don't just make sense of history through stories make sense of history through illustrations and maps does that mean you could almost draw a map and you could say this these bits are kind of
They had low numbers. And so in a sense, maybe they were already a threatened species. And then modern humans came out of Africa about 60,000 years ago, started entering the territory of the Neanderthals. And that may have eventually just destabilized them so much that they just went extinct. Does that mean you could almost draw a map? Tom was talking about history. And, you know, we don't just make sense of history through stories make sense of history through illustrations and maps does that mean you could almost draw a map and you could say this these bits are kind of|||他们的数量很少。所以从某种意义上说，也许他们当时就已经是一个受到威胁的物种了。然后，现代人在大约6万年前走出了非洲，开始进入尼安德特人的领地。这最终可能彻底动摇了他们的根基，导致他们走向了灭绝。这是否意味着你几乎可以画出一张地图？汤姆刚才在谈论历史。而且，你知道，我们不仅仅通过故事来理解历史，还通过插图和地图来理解历史。这是否意味着你几乎可以画出一张地图，然后说这些部分是某种——
human inhabited or sorry modern human kind of homo sapiens inhabited and these bits are kind of neanderthal territory or something i mean because you're suggesting that they're in different places basically yeah so we don't have the data to put them on the map at the same time in the same places except in a couple of places so broadly speaking the neanderthals were in occupation of europe from their lineage at least from from more than 400 000 years ago down to about 40 000 ago. Most of the fossils we find are Neanderthal in that time zone. But there are a few exceptions. So there is a fossil from Greece that I was involved in studying
human inhabited or sorry modern human kind of homo sapiens inhabited and these bits are kind of neanderthal territory or something i mean because you're suggesting that they're in different places basically yeah so we don't have the data to put them on the map at the same time in the same places except in a couple of places so broadly speaking the neanderthals were in occupation of europe from their lineage at least from from more than 400 000 years ago down to about 40 000 ago. Most of the fossils we find are Neanderthal in that time zone. But there are a few exceptions. So there is a fossil from Greece that I was involved in studying|||人类居住的，或者说抱歉，现代人——智人居住的，而这些部分是尼安德特人的领地之类的？我的意思是，因为你刚才暗示他们基本上身处不同的地方——是的，所以我们没有足够的数据把他们在同一时间、同一地点标注在地图上，除了极少数几个地方。所以大体而言，从他们的谱系来看，尼安德特人至少在40多万年前一直到大约4万年前，一直占据着欧洲。我们在那个时间段发现的大多数化石都是尼安德特人的。但也有一些例外。比如希腊的一个化石，我曾参与过研究，
from a site called Epidema in the Peloponnese. And that cave site has what seems to be a Homo sapiens fossil over 200,000 years old, and then after it, a Neanderthal fossil. So there we've got what may be a brief appearance of modern humans, or at least Homo sapiens, over 200,000 years ago in the Eastern Mediterranean, but then it goes again. And then we come on to the period between 40,000 and 50,000 years ago,
from a site called Epidema in the Peloponnese. And that cave site has what seems to be a Homo sapiens fossil over 200,000 years old, and then after it, a Neanderthal fossil. So there we've got what may be a brief appearance of modern humans, or at least Homo sapiens, over 200,000 years old in the Eastern Mediterranean, but then it goes again. And then we come on to the period between 40,000 and 50,000 years ago,|||那个遗址位于伯罗奔尼撒半岛的阿皮迪马（Apidima）。那个洞穴遗址中似乎包含了一块距今超过20万年的智人化石，紧随其后的则是一块尼安德特人化石。所以在那里，我们可能发现了现代人——或者至少是智人——在20万年前东地中海地区的一次短暂出现，但随后他们又消失了。然后我们来到了距今4万到5万年前的时期，
and it looks like we have kind of a similar story, that modern humans are kind of appearing in Europe briefly, but then disappearing again. So the Neanderthals remain the main occupants of Europe until about 40,000 years ago when they go extinct. But modern humans are making, if you like, incursions, dispersals into Neanderthal territory. And eventually, by about 41,000 years, modern humans are there in sufficiently
and it looks like we have kind of a similar story, that modern humans are kind of appearing in Europe briefly, but then disappearing again. So the Neanderthals remain the main occupants of Europe until about 40,000 years ago when they go extinct. But modern humans are making, if you like, incursions, dispersals into Neanderthal territory. And eventually, by about 41,000 years, modern humans are there in sufficiently|||情况似乎与此类似：现代人似乎在欧洲短暂出现，随后又再次消失。因此，尼安德特人一直保持着欧洲主要居住者的地位，直到大约4万年前他们走向灭绝。但现代人正在对尼安德特人的领地进行——如果你愿意这么说的话——侵入和扩散。最终，到大约4.1万年前，现代人以足够庞大的
large numbers that they effectively take over from the Neanderthals. And one of the interesting things is, and this is purely speculation because we don't have all the data, is that we know that a number of those modern humans that were moving into Neanderthal territory over 40,000 years ago, a number of them show signs of interbreeding with the Neanderthals. And so it's possible that Neanderthal individuals, male or female, were being taken into the modern human groups. Now, if the Neanderthals were fewer in number, they're losing prime age breeding individuals into the modern human groups. And that would be one way in which they might have just faded away. Because if you're taking prime age adults, breeding individuals out of a population,
large numbers that they effectively take over from the Neanderthals. And one of the interesting things is, and this is purely speculation because we don't have all the data, is that we know that a number of those modern humans that were moving into Neanderthal territory over 40,000 years ago, a number of them show signs of interbreeding with the Neanderthals. And so it's possible that Neanderthal individuals, male or female, were being taken into the modern human groups. Now, if the Neanderthals were fewer in number, they're losing prime age breeding individuals into the modern human groups. And that would be one way in which they might have just faded away. Because if you're taking prime age adults, breeding individuals out of a population,|||数量出现在那里，并有效地取代了尼安德特人。其中有趣的一点是——这纯粹是推测，因为我们并没有掌握所有数据——我们知道，在4万多年前移入尼安德特人领地的那些现代人中，有相当一部分人表现出了与尼安德特人发生基因交流（杂交）的迹象。因此，当时尼安德特人个体（无论是男性还是女性）被吸纳进现代人群体中是有可能的。现在，如果尼安德特人的数量较少，他们正不断失去处于黄金生育年龄的个体，这些个体流入了现代人群体中。这可能会成为他们逐渐消亡的一种方式。因为如果你把正值壮年、具备繁殖能力的成年个体从一个种群中抽离出去，
that population is not going to be able to sustain itself if that behavior continues. So what's odd is that the late Neanderthals we have DNA for don't show evidence of DNA from modern humans. So either the interbreeding was mainly going one way into modern human gene pools and Neanderthals are being taken out of their own gene pool, or the interbreeding in the other direction was unsuccessful and those individuals did not survive to breed on. So we're beginning to learn about this interesting phase and how the interbreeding in the other direction was unsuccessful and those individuals did not survive to breed on. So we're beginning to learn about this interesting phase and how the interbreeding even happened.
that population is not going to be able to sustain itself if that behavior continues. So what's odd is that the late Neanderthals we have DNA for don't show evidence of DNA from modern humans. So either the interbreeding was mainly going one way into modern human gene pools and Neanderthals are being taken out of their own gene pool, or the interbreeding in the other direction was unsuccessful and those individuals did not survive to breed on. So we're beginning to learn about this interesting phase and how the interbreeding in the other direction was unsuccessful and those individuals did not survive to breed on. So we're beginning to learn about this interesting phase and how the interbreeding even happened.|||如果这种行为持续下去，那个种群将无法维持自身。奇怪的是，我们提取到DNA的晚期尼安德特人并没有显示出来自现代人的DNA证据。因此，要么这种基因交流主要是单向流入现代人的基因库，而尼安德特人被抽离出了他们自己的基因库；要么反方向的基因交流并不成功，那些个体没有存活下来并继续繁衍后代。所以我们开始逐渐了解这个有趣的阶段，以及反方向的基因交流为何不成功、那些个体为何未能存活并繁衍后代。我们正在开始了解这个有趣的阶段，以及基因交流究竟是如何发生的。
We don't really know the details. Was it friendly? Was it hostile, capturing females, for example, which does happen sometimes in chimpanzee groups and some hunter-gatherer groups? Was it adopting orphan babies? Those are all possibilities, and indeed, all of those things could have happened at different times
We don't really know the details. Was it friendly? Was it hostile, capturing females, for example, which does happen sometimes in chimpanzee groups and some hunter-gatherer groups? Was it adopting orphan babies? Those are all possibilities, and indeed, all of those things could have happened at different times|||我们其实并不清楚其中的细节。它是友好的吗？还是充满敌意的？比如通过掠夺女性——这在黑猩猩群体和某些狩猎采集群体中确实有时会发生。还是收养了孤儿？这些都是有可能的。事实上，所有这些事情都可能在不同的时间、
in different places. So eventually, we'll have more data to actually reconstruct how these people were interbreeding. It will be possible one day to tell whether it was the interbreeding of Neanderthals was mainly through females or males or... How? How will we possibly... How do we know that? Forgive my ignorance. Well, because of the X and Y chromosomes, for example, that obviously males have an X and a Y chromosome,
in different places. So eventually, we'll have more data to actually reconstruct how these people were interbreeding. It will be possible one day to tell whether it was the interbreeding of Neanderthals was mainly through females or males or... How? How will we possibly... How do we know that? Forgive my ignorance. Well, because of the X and Y chromosomes, for example, that obviously males have an X and a Y chromosome,|||不同的地方发生过。所以最终，我们将拥有更多的数据来真正还原这些人是如何进行基因交流的。总有一天，我们将能够分辨出尼安德特人的基因交流究竟主要是通过女性、还是通过男性来完成的……怎么做？我们怎么可能……我们是怎么知道这一点的？请原谅我的无知。嗯，这是因为X和Y染色体。例如，很显然男性拥有一个X和一个Y染色体，
females have two X chromosomes. Of course, there are other chromosome mixtures as well, but those are the two main mixtures. And so eventually, geneticists will be able to reconstruct you know the neanderthal dna that's coming in amazing could it be mediated through mainly through females or males so if it was females that might imply that they were kind of slaves or or that they were being kidnapped for breeding purposes basically yes yes it's possible uh or it might be even the the the mating systems of these people meant that the females were mobile and moving into male groups predominantly rather than the other way around.
females have two X chromosomes. Of course, there are other chromosome mixtures as well, but those are the two main mixtures. And so eventually, geneticists will be able to reconstruct you know the neanderthal dna that's coming in amazing could it be mediated through mainly through females or males so if it was females that might imply that they were kind of slaves or or that they were being kidnapped for breeding purposes basically yes yes it's possible uh or it might be even the the the mating systems of these people meant that the females were mobile and moving into male groups predominantly rather than the other way around.|||而女性拥有两个X染色体。当然，还有其他的染色体组合方式，但这两种是主要的组合。因此最终，遗传学家将能够还原——你知道的——融入进来的尼安德特人DNA。太惊人了！这究竟主要是通过女性还是通过男性介导的呢？所以如果是通过女性，那可能意味着她们有点像奴隶，或者说她们基本上是被绑架来用于繁育后代的？是的，是的，这是有可能的。嗯，或者甚至可能意味着这些人的交配系统决定了女性具有更高的流动性，她们主要会融入到男性的群体中，而不是反过来。
So there could even be social reasons why it might be in that direction. So, yeah, there's a lot to learn about this time period, and it will be interesting to see how the data unfold on this. Chris, we really ought to go for a break. And when we come back, I love to talk about what we we can say about neanderthal society presumably societies i'm guessing there were lots of different kinds but just just on this topic i mean what what seems really interesting about the way that neanderthals have been understood right from the beginning is that they've kind of presided provided um a mirror that is held up to anxieties and assumptions among contemporary societies. And the way that we've understood Neanderthals has kind of evolved as our cultural political sensibilities have evolved as well. And I'm guessing that at the moment, with all the DNA, with all the kind of
So there could even be social reasons why it might be in that direction. So, yeah, there's a lot to learn about this time period, and it will be interesting to see how the data unfold on this. Chris, we really ought to go for a break. And when we come back, I love to talk about what we we can say about neanderthal society presumably societies i'm guessing there were lots of different kinds but just just on this topic i mean what what seems really interesting about the way that neanderthals have been understood right from the beginning is that they've kind of presided provided um a mirror that is held up to anxieties and assumptions among contemporary societies. And the way that we've understood Neanderthals has kind of evolved as our cultural political sensibilities have evolved as well. And I'm guessing that at the moment, with all the DNA, with all the kind of|||所以朝这个方向发展甚至可能存在社会原因。所以，是的，关于这个时期还有很多东西需要了解，看到相关数据如何展开将是一件非常有趣的事情。克里斯，我们真的该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我很想谈谈关于尼安德特人社会——我猜应该有许多不同种类的社会——我们究竟能说些什么。但仅就这个话题而言，我的意思是，关于尼安德特人自最初被发现以来所受到的理解，最有趣的一点在于：他们提供了一面镜子，映照出当代社会中的种种焦虑和假设。我们理解尼安德特人的方式，随着我们文化和政治敏锐性的演变而演变。我猜现在，伴随着所有的DNA研究，伴随着各种——
scientific study, with all the kind of objectivity that scientists like yourself bring to it. Nevertheless, these are quite politically sensitive areas, the question of migration, of population replacement, all this kind of stuff. Do you think that, you know, just as in the 60s, people were seeing flower power reflected back in burial sites and so on. Do you think now, with all the kind of current political anxieties that are roiling Western societies, is that still going on? In other words, is how we understand Neanderthals and particularly their relationship to Homo sapiens kind of determined by politics as much as by science?
scientific study, with all the kind of objectivity that scientists like yourself bring to it. Nevertheless, these are quite politically sensitive areas, the question of migration, of population replacement, all this kind of stuff. Do you think that, you know, just as in the 60s, people were seeing flower power reflected back in burial sites and so on. Do you think now, with all the kind of current political anxieties that are roiling Western societies, is that still going on? In other words, is how we understand Neanderthals and particularly their relationship to Homo sapiens kind of determined by politics as much as by science?|||科学研究，以及像你这样的科学家所带来的那种客观性。然而，这些都是相当具有政治敏感性的领域，比如人口迁移、人口更替等问题。你认为——正如在60年代人们在墓葬遗址中看到了“花之力量”的投射一样——你认为现在，随着那些动荡着西方社会的种种当前政治焦虑，这种现象还在继续吗？换句话说，我们对尼安德特人、尤其是他们与智人关系的理解，在很大程度上是由政治决定的，还是由科学决定的？
Well, it's certainly coming into it now. So there are some people who think that even calling the Neanderthals a different species is dangerous. It's in a sense racist that we're setting up differences in humanity, which can then be applied to populations today. I take a different view because for me, our species, Homo sapiens, we can diagnose it by shared features. That is how we do it. We look at the shared features of modern humans around the world today. And that's how we can say the Neanderthals are a different species because they don't show those shared features. Equally, geneticists can look at the modern human genome and they can find a suite of features there which are characterized by modern humans around the world which we don't find in the Neanderthals so for me having Neanderthals as a distinct species doesn't in a sense produce racial divisions within modern
嗯，现在确实正朝着这个方向发展。所以有些人认为，甚至把尼安德特人称作一个不同的物种都是危险的。从某种意义上说，这是种族主义，因为我们在人类中划分出差异，而这些差异随后可能会被应用到当今的人群中。我持有不同的观点，因为对我而言，我们这个物种——智人，可以通过共同的特征来进行鉴定。我们就是这样做的。我们观察当今世界各地现代人类的共同特征。这就是为什么我们可以说尼安德特人是不同的物种，因为他们没有表现出那些共同特征。同样，遗传学家可以观察现代人类的基因组，他们可以在其中发现一组特征，这些特征是世界各地现代人类所特有的，但在尼安德特人身上找不到。因此，对我和谐而言，将尼安德特人视为一个独立的物种，并不会在现代
humans for me it's the opposite I think you know what unites us is what unites us as a species compared with the Neanderthals and these earlier human species brilliant okay so um we'll take a break now when we come back maybe we could look at and work out what we know about how Neanderthals lived I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history uh chris stringer professor chris stringer has been replenishing his energy with some some fruit tom holland has been honing his neanderthal impression
人类中产生种族划分。对我来说，情况恰恰相反。我认为，你知道，将我们联系在一起的是我们作为一个物种与尼安德特人以及这些早期人类物种相比的共同点。太好了，好吧，那么……我们现在休息一下。回来后，也许我们可以了解并弄清楚我们所知道的关于尼安德特人生活方式的信息。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《剩余娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 theresaentertainment.com。那是《剩余历史》（The Rest Is History）……呃，克里斯·斯特林格（Chris Stringer）教授一直在吃一些水果来补充体力，汤姆·霍兰德一直在磨练他的尼安德特人模仿秀，
which i'm reliably assured he will be doing at the end of this uh episode and tom you had a question for chris didn't you about Neanderthal what we know of Neanderthal so both physically and kind of socially well I guess I say Chris I guess Dominic's laid down this challenge I have to do an impression of of a Neanderthal would we have any way of knowing what a Neanderthal sound like I mean presumably they have language um what can we say about language how they sounded what do we know about that yeah that's a very good question obviously a question of great interest and it's one of the most difficult ones to answer of course so some people have tried to reconstruct what a Neanderthal would sound like from the anatomy
据我可靠保证，他将在本集结束时表演这个。汤姆，你对克里斯有个问题吧？关于尼安德特人，我们对尼安德特人的了解，无论是生理上的还是社会层面的？好吧，我想说，克里斯，我想多米尼克已经抛出了这个挑战，我必须模仿一个尼安德特人。我们有什么方法知道尼安德特人听起来是什么样的吗？我的意思是，他们大概有语言……关于语言，我们能说些什么？他们听起来是怎样的？我们对此了解多少？是的，这是一个非常好的问题，显然是一个备受关注的问题，而且这也是最难回答的问题之一。所以，有些人试图从解剖学角度重建尼安德特人的声音，
and possibly their voice box was not as deeply placed as ours so they may have actually had a higher pitch voice oh well there's i'm looking forward to your reconstruction so good tom if you search on the bbc uh website you'll find a very amusing reconstruction there a modern attempt to sound like a neanderthal it won't be as amusing as this one it's very amusing and perhaps tom should view that before he does his reconstruction but it's very funny i perhaps tom should view that before he does his reconstruction but it's very funny i i recommend you find it and have a laugh but in reality yes of course they may have been slightly different in sound um we can tell from the uh ear bones actually are preserved of neanderthals to compare with modern humans and they are slightly differently shaped to our own
并且他们的声匣可能不像我们的那样深陷，所以他们实际上可能拥有更高音调的声音。哦，好吧，我很期待你的重建。很好，汤姆，如果你在BBC网站上搜索，你会发现一个非常有趣的重建，那是现代人试图模仿尼安德特人声音的尝试。它不会像这个这么有趣。非常有趣，也许汤姆在做他的重建之前应该先看看那个。但它非常搞笑，也许汤姆在做他的重建之前应该先看看那个。但它非常搞笑，我建议你找来看看并笑一笑。但实际上，是的，当然，他们的声音可能略有不同。我们可以从尼安德特人保存下来的耳骨看出这一点，将其与现代人类进行比较，它们的形状与我们的耳骨略有不同。
ear bones but when you test the acoustic properties of the Neanderthal hearing system as much as we can reconstruct it it seems to be similar to our own in its range of hearing so at least from that point of view similar and some people think that the Neanderthal vocal tract would not have been as versatile as ours it couldn't produce as many sounds that's that's a possibility uh but of course there was a really let's say extreme reconstruction of Neanderthals that suggested they only had 20 percent of the vocal repertoire uh sounds that we could make but as someone pointed out at the time there are many modern human languages that only make 20 percent
但当你测试尼安德特人听觉系统的声学特性（在我们能重建的范围内）时，它在听力范围上似乎与我们自己的相似。所以至少从那个角度来看是相似的。有些人认为尼安德特人的声道不像我们的那么灵活，无法发出那么多的声音，这是一种可能性。但当然，也有过一种非常极端的尼安德特人重建方案，暗示他们只拥有我们能发出的声音曲目中百分之二十的声音。但正如当时有人指出的那样，许多现代人类语言也只使用你可以发出的声音的百分之二十，
of the sounds you could make so on its own that wouldn't limit the Neanderthals. Language is a product of the brain and language evolves out of social complexity. So for me, we know from their archaeology that the Neanderthals led complex lives. And I think that that signifies they would have had some form of speech and language. And it may not have been as complex as the language we're using now. Perhaps their language did not have concepts of deep time. We don't know. Abstraction, we don't know.
因此单凭这一点并不会限制尼安德特人。语言是大脑的产物，语言是从社会复杂性中进化而来的。因此，在我看来，我们从他们的考古学中知道，尼安德特人的生活很复杂。我认为这表明他们拥有某种形式的言语和语言。它的复杂程度可能不像我们现在使用的语言那样高。也许他们的语言没有深层时间的观念。我们不知道。抽象概念，我们也不知道。
But certainly in practical terms, I think the Neanderthals must have had language. They're leading complex lives. They're surviving under difficult conditions. They're hunting difficult animals. They're moving over the landscape in complex ways and living in relatively large groups. So I think I would certainly give them a language capability. So the idea that they have very high pitch voices seems counterintuitive because physically they're larger than humans, are they kind of have to eat more the energy demands on them are greater obviously we've got to remember that modern humans around the world vary greatly in size and shape so it depends who we're comparing them with but yes compared with
但肯定的是，在实际层面上，我认为尼安德特人一定拥有语言。他们的生活很复杂。他们在恶劣的条件下生存。他们猎杀凶猛的动物。他们在复杂的景观中移动，并生活在相对较大的群体中。所以我认为我绝对会赋予他们语言能力。所以，他们声音很高的这种观点似乎与直觉相悖，因为在生理上他们比人类更大。他们是不是必须吃更多东西？他们面临的能量需求更大？显然，我们必须记住，世界各地的现代人类在体型和形状上有很大差异，所以这取决于我们在和谁进行比较。但是的，与……相比，
you know let's say the average european neanderthals were shorter and wider, and they were heavily bodied, so they were very muscular and very powerfully built, very powerful upper body. You probably wouldn't want to get in a wrestling match with a Neanderthal. So they're more like me than like Tom. Yeah, I don't want to have stereotypes, but maybe, maybe. Do that DNA test, Dominic. We don't know how much hair they had, Dominic. Right, that's a bit worrying. Yes, even body hair, we don't know.
你知道，比方说，平均欧洲人，尼安德特人更矮、更宽，而且体格魁梧，所以他们非常肌肉发达，体格非常健壮，上半身非常强壮。你可能不想和尼安德特人进行摔跤比赛。所以他们更像我，而不像汤姆。是的，我不想有刻板印象，但也许，也许。去做那个DNA测试吧，多米尼克。我们不知道他们有多少头发，多米尼克。好吧，这有点令人担忧。是的，甚至连体毛，我们也不知道。
Obviously, the reconstructions of Neanderthals through time, if we look at them, we can see this pendulum swinging of making them look very human or very subhuman. And now the reconstructions in museums, including our own in London, show them as very human and relatively hairless but of course we don't actually know how much body hair they had and it probably varied through time at times they lived in very cold conditions and a short and wide body would be a good body shape to have because you're minimizing your surface area to save heat they may have had layers of subcutaneous
显然，随着时间的推移，对尼安德特人的重建，如果我们回顾一下，我们可以看到这种摇摆不定：有时让他们看起来非常像人类，有时又非常像类人生物。现在博物馆里的重建，包括我们伦敦的那座，把他们描绘得非常像人类，而且相对没有体毛。但当然，我们实际上并不知道他们有多少体毛，而且它可能随时间而变化。有时他们生活在非常寒冷的环境中，又矮又宽的身材是一个很好的体型，因为你可以最大限度地减少表面积来保持热量。他们可能拥有几层皮下
fat to help them in that adaptation and I'm sure their culture you know they would have had layers of subcutaneous fat uh to help them in that adaptation um and i'm sure their culture you know they would have had some form of clothing um they would have had shelters things like that but of course most of the evidence of that has disappeared but now and again we do find very strange structures that were made by neanderthals so um there's a site in France called Bruniquel, a Bruniquel cave, one of many caves in that Bruniquel area. And one very deep cave has an astonishing discovery. So deep in the cave, hundreds of meters in the dark zone of that cave, archaeologists have recovered a couple of stone structures deep in this cave. They're basically elliptical structures, which are basically dry stone walls made out of stalagmites.
脂肪来帮助他们适应这种环境，而且我确信他们的文化，你知道，他们会拥有某种形式的衣物，他们会有住所之类的事情。但当然，这方面的证据大多已经消失了。不过，我们偶尔确实会发现一些由尼安德特人建造的非常奇怪的结构。所以，在法国有一个叫布伦尼盖尔（Bruniquel）的地方，布伦尼盖尔洞穴，那是布伦尼盖尔地区众多洞穴之一。在一个非常深的洞穴里有一个惊人的发现。在这座洞穴深处，在距离黑暗区数百米的地方，考古学家在这个洞穴深处发现了一对石头结构。它们基本上是椭圆形的结构，本质上是由石笋制成的干砌石墙。
So the Neanderthals went deep into this cave, way beyond the daylight zone. They must have had fire to do that lighting. And they took stalagmites, broke them up, and built dry stone walls to make these elliptical structures. There are at least two of them. And, you know, that's that's all we've got at the moment of these strange structures deep in the cave. Why were they there? Was this some kind of ritual behavior? Were they living down in the cave? The area has yet to be excavated systematically, so we don't really know know what there are are signs of bones that have
所以尼安德特人深入这个洞穴，远远超出了日光区。他们为了照明一定有火。他们把石笋拿来，砸碎，然后建造干砌石墙来制作这些椭圆形结构。至少有两个这样的结构。而且，你知道，这就是目前我们关于洞穴深处这些奇怪结构的所有信息。它们为什么在那里？这是一种某种仪式行为吗？他们住在洞穴里吗？该地区尚未进行系统的发掘，所以我们并不知道这里是否有骨骼的迹象。
been burnt so some animal bones are high in fat and they can actually be burnt for light and so actually they were burning pieces of bone at this site to provide light it's possible this was i mean this was during a cold phase about 175 000 years ago and maybe the cave actually was relatively warmer we know that a river actually went through the cave so it it came from the surface through the cave and then out again to the surface so it's possible the neanderthals were tracking that river in going down into the cave but why they would have set up this camp if that's what it is deep in the cave like that uh is is a question we simply cannot answer and some people think it signifies some ritual behavior yeah um i think it might be a more practical thing that they were
它们被烧毁了。所以一些动物骨骼富含脂肪，它们实际上可以被燃烧来提供光线。因此，实际上他们在这个地方燃烧骨头碎片来提供光线。这可能是——我的意思是，这是在大约17.5万年前的一个寒冷时期发生的，也许洞穴实际上相对更暖和。我们知道，实际上有一条河流流经洞穴，所以它从地表流经洞穴，然后又流回地表。因此，尼安德特人进入洞穴时可能是顺着那条河流追踪的。但是，如果这是他们建的营地的话，他们为什么要在洞穴深处建立这样一个营地呢？这是一个我们根本无法回答的问题。有些人认为这标志着某种仪式行为。
actually living down there but we we simply don't know but it shows the complexity of their behavior because it could be not much later cave art or something i mean kind of monumental or some temple or something like that is that going too far you know archaeologists you know the joke is that you know when an archaeologist can't explain something they say it's a richer object and that's what we're up against here with this this structure we simply don't know what it is and when it can be excavated systematically. So what we don't know is what's actually on the floor of these structures that hasn't been excavated yet. So if there are stone tools and butchered animal bones, then obviously they were living there. But if there aren't any of those things, then that might promote the belief that this is some kind of special ritual structure.
是的，呃，我认为这可能是一件更务实的事情，他们实际上就住在那里，但我们根本不知道。但这显示了他们行为的复杂性。因为这可能是不久之后的洞穴壁画之类的东西。我的意思是，某种纪念碑或某种寺庙之类的东西？这会不会太过了？你知道，考古学家，你知道那个笑话：当考古学家无法解释某事时，他们就会说这是一件宗教物品。这就是我们在这里面对这种结构时所处的情况：我们根本不知道它是什么，除非能对它进行系统发掘。所以我们不知道的是，这些结构的地面上到底有什么，这还没有被发掘。因此，如果那里有石器和被屠宰的动物骨骼，那么显然他们住在那里。但如果没有这些东西，那么这可能会促进人们的信念，即这是一种特殊的宗教结构。
And you mentioned cave art. And of that's that's one of the things that more than 20 years ago was supposed to separate us from the Neanderthals so in Africa we were developing symbolic expression we were using red ochre and we were engraving and and when we came out of Africa we started to paint caves and these beautiful cave paintings of of animals that we find in many caves. Apparently, that was something the Neanderthals simply couldn't do. But we now know that there are many sites where there's lots of ochre, red ochre and dark pigments collected by Neanderthals in really large quantities. Now, some of it, you can use ochre for practical purposes,
你提到了洞穴壁画。这是20多年前被认为将我们与尼安德特人区分开来的事情之一。所以在非洲，我们正在发展象征性表达，我们使用红赭石，我们进行雕刻。当我们离开非洲时，我们在洞穴里作画，这些我们在许多洞穴中发现的美丽的动物洞穴壁画。显然，那是尼安德特人根本做不到的事情。但我们现在知道，有许多遗址拥有大量由尼安德特人收集的赭石、红赭石和深色颜料，数量非常巨大。现在，其中一部分，你可能会将赭石用于实际目的，
apparently softening skins, apparently rubbing on the skin as an insecticide, things like that. But there's so much of it that it looks like it was being used for marking bodies and potentially marking cave walls. And now from Spain, there are sites dating from more than 60,000 years ago, which have markings on the walls that seem to be made by Neanderthals. It is controversial. There are some people who challenge the dating. But I think it's quite likely with all that pigment around that Neanderthals were marking their bodies. And we know that Neanderthals made pendants.
显然可以用来软化兽皮，显然可以作为杀虫剂涂抹在皮肤上，诸如此类的事情。但它的数量如此之多，看起来它被用于标记身体，并可能用于标记洞穴墙壁。现在在西班牙，有一些可以追溯到6万多年前的遗址，墙壁上有似乎由尼安德特人制作的标记。这是有争议的。有些人对年代测定提出质疑。但我认为，考虑到周围有那么多的颜料，尼安德特人很可能在他们的身体上做标记。我们知道尼安德特人制作挂件。
They made jewelry. We have examples of pierced animal teeth from Neanderthal sites. We have shells with holes in that look like they've been suspended and even coloured with ochre. And there are even talons of birds of prey that look like they've been suspended as jewellery or pendants. So the Neanderthals had that. They were signalling to each other in a way that we would see as very very human and Chris what about burials so so the idea in the 60s that they were buried with with flowers is not thought to be true anymore but there is evidence that they
他们制作珠宝。我们有来自尼安德特人遗址的有孔动物牙齿的例子。我们有带孔的贝壳，看起来像是被悬挂起来的，甚至还涂上了赭石。甚至还有猛禽的爪子，看起来像是作为珠宝或吊坠悬挂着。所以尼安德特人拥有这些。他们以一种我们认为非常非常人性化的方式向彼此发出信号。克里斯，关于埋葬呢？所以，60年代认为他们是用花朵安葬的这种观点，现在被认为不再正确了，但有证据表明他们
were they had some sense perhaps of of an afterlife that they were they weren't just kind of leaving bodies to rot yes that's right's right. So I think, you know, for me, there is enough, more than enough evidence that Neanderthals were burying their dead. The fact that we've got so many Neanderthal skeletons, some people have challenged that these were intentional burials, that these were individuals whose bodies just washed into a crevice in a cave, or it was a rock fall and the Neanderthal was buried under a load of rocks. That could certainly have happened. But I think there are enough examples now that we can say that Neanderthals intentionally buried their dead and not just adults.
拥有某种对来世的感知，也许他们不仅仅是把尸体留在那儿腐烂。是的，没错，没错。所以我觉得，对我来说，有足够的、甚至远远足够的证据表明尼安德特人在埋葬他们的死者。事实上，我们拥有这么多的尼安德特人骨骼——有些人质疑这些是否是有意埋葬，认为这些个体的尸体只是被冲进洞穴的裂缝中，或者那是岩石崩塌，尼安德特人被压在了一堆石头下面。这当然可能发生。但我认为现在有足够多的例子，我们可以说尼安德特人是有意埋葬他们的死者的，而且不仅仅是成年人。
This is these barriers of children as well. So, yes, I think they buried their dead. Now, of course, interpreting why they did it is another matter. Yeah. Was it, you know, did it start off as hygienic maybe that they didn't want to leave a body out on the surface to attract hyenas and uh and dangerous other predators um so the bodies were covered up um just to get them out the way um perhaps uh it could be an extension of care because one of the individuals from Shanidar,
这也是对儿童的埋葬。所以，是的，我认为他们埋葬了死者。现在，当然，解释他们为什么这样做是另一回事。是的，它是，你知道，它最初是为了卫生吗？也许他们不想把尸体留在地面上吸引鬣狗和其他危险的捕食者，所以尸体被盖起来，只是为了把它们弄开。也许，这可能是关怀的延伸，因为来自沙尼达尔（Shanidar）的其中一个个体，
Shanidar 1, the first one that was discovered, probably a burial, that individual was severely disabled for the last at least probably 10 years of his life. That's amazing. Yeah. Yes. He was a cripple, possibly blind in one eye. And so it seems very likely people were provisioning for him. And maybe the burial of that individual is caring for the body after death. So you've invested this care in that person during their life and you invest care when they die as well.
沙尼达尔1号，第一个被发现的个体，可能是一个墓葬。该个体在他生命最后的至少10年里严重残疾。这太惊人了。是的。是的。他是个瘸子，可能一只眼睛瞎了。所以看起来很有可能人们一直在为他提供物资。也许对那个个体的埋葬是对死后身体的关怀。所以你在那个人生前对他倾注了这种关怀，当他们死后你也倾注了关怀。
Whether there's a concept of an afterlife, maybe that is an add on at a later stage. But who knows? Neanderthals could have had that concept too. Well Chris so is there any sense that I mean if we look at Homo sapiens history in a sense I mean we can cast it as a tale of progress and I use the word very advisedly but technological advances leading to ever more complicated societies do we do we have any sense of that happening with the Neanderthals is there a sense that their society is becoming more technologically advanced are they differing evolving changing over time well i think they must have been uh there's certainly a change uh significant change of behavior that we see both in neanderthals and modern human evolution where the earliest examples
至于是否存在来世的概念，也许那是后来才加上去的。但谁知道呢？尼安德特人也可能拥有这种概念。好吧，克里斯，那么有没有这样一种感觉：如果我们回顾智人的历史，从某种意义上说，我们可以把它描绘成一个关于进步的故事——我非常审慎地使用这个词——技术进步导致了日益复杂的社会？我们是否有任何迹象表明这种事情发生在尼安德特人身上？有没有一种感觉，他们的社会在技术上变得越来越先进？他们在随着时间推移而不同、进化、改变？嗯，我想他们一定是的。这肯定是一个改变，我们在尼安德特人和现代人类进化中都看到了显着的行为变化，其中最早的例子
of uh probably the neanderthal lineage and the Sapiens lineage are associated with stone tools that we call hand axes. So these are almond shaped, often pointed, bifacially worked tools. They sit in the hand nicely and we call them hand axes. We don't know what the people at the time called them of course so these hand axes were associated with early neanderthals and with early homo sapiens in in africa but about 300,000 years ago there's a switch in behavior and we start to see the appearance of what are called prepared prepared core tools sometimes called lavalois tools. And there, the shape of the artifact is predetermined. You map out in the core the shape you want your flake to be, and then you strike it off with a single blow, and you have a predetermined shape of tool. So this technology spreads across much of the
可能属于尼安德特人谱系和智人谱系的石器，我们称之为手斧。这些是扁桃形状的，通常带尖的，双面加工的工具。它们很好地握在手里，我们称之为手斧。当然，我们不知道当时的人们怎么称呼它们。所以这些手斧与非洲的早期尼安德特人和早期智人有关。但在大约30万年前，行为发生了转变，我们开始看到被称为“预制核心工具”（有时称为勒瓦卢瓦工具，Levallois tools）的出现。在那里，人工制品的形状是预先确定的。你在核心中规划出你希望剥片呈现的形状，然后用一次打击将其敲下，你就得到了一个预先确定形状的工具。所以这项技术传播到了大部分
Neanderthal and early Homo sapiens world. And that's then the dominant technology for the next 200,000 years. So there is that change that goes on in both Neanderthals and early Homo sapiens. And even within that, you do see many different tool types. So within Neanderthals, we see them capable of producing tools that would have been good for working skins. So they're wearing clothes? We assume so, yeah. I mean, again, the evidence is, you know, there's no direct evidence for that really, but the fact they've got this technology,
尼安德特人和早期智人的世界。在接下来的20万年里，这成为了主导技术。因此，尼安德特人和早期智人都发生了这种变化。即使在其中，你也能看到许多不同的工具类型。所以在尼安德特人中，我们看到他们有能力生产适合加工兽皮的工具。所以他们穿衣服？我们认为是这样的，是的。我的意思是，同样，证据是，你知道，真的没有直接证据证明这一点，但他们拥有这项技术的事实，
and we know that the tools themselves show wear on them. Sometimes there are bone tools that have been used to, which today would be used to rub skins, and they show a polish on the end. So those tools are known from Neanderthal sites so Neanderthals were pretty certainly working skins for clothing I mean they're living in at times very severe winters yeah so we assume they must have had some form of clothing Chris what's about their social their social structure do they have because you've alluded a few times to their
而且我们知道工具本身显示出磨损。有时会有骨制工具，这些工具今天会被用来揉搓兽皮，它们的末端呈现出抛光效果。所以这些工具在尼安德特人遗址中是已知的。因此，尼安德特人几乎可以肯定是在加工兽皮来制作衣服。我的意思是，他们有时生活在非常严酷的冬天。是的，所以我们假设他们一定拥有某种形式的衣服。克里斯，关于他们的社会结构呢？他们有没有——因为你已经好几次提到他们的
social structure but are they in you're saying they're in big groups but do we have any sense of are they big enough groups to be like a clan or a tribe or a extended family or what do we think they are yeah we can't really say about numbers in total um i mean people have reconstructed that groups within caves when you look at flint scatters and sizes of habitation, that Neanderthals could be in groups of 20 or 30. But whether they were in much bigger aggregations at times, we simply don't know. As I mentioned already, probably towards the end of their time, there's genetic evidence that Neanderthals were relatively low in variation. And there's some evidence of inbreeding in some Neanderthal sites. We see from the DNA that individuals are closely related. And there's a site in Spain where you have quite a few anomalies
社会结构了——他们是在大群体中吗？我们是否有任何感觉，他们是否大到足以成为一个氏族、一个部落、一个大家庭，或者我们认为他们是什么？是的，我们无法真正确定总人数。我的意思是，人们通过观察燧石散落物和居住规模，重建出洞穴内的群体，尼安德特人的群体可能由20或30人组成。但他们有时是否处于更大的聚集体中，我们根本不知道。正如我之前已经提到的，可能在他们时代的末期，有遗传证据表明尼安德特人的基因变异相对较低。并且在一些尼安德特人遗址中有近亲繁殖的证据。我们从DNA中看到个体之间密切相关。在西班牙的一个遗址中，你发现了很多异常现象，
in the skeletons of the Neanderthals from that site that suggests that they could have been inbreeding and therefore that's not good for the genetic health of the population. So at times the Neanderthals were challenged. And there's the tricky matter of cannibalism. We haven't come on to that one yet, but we know that both Neanderthals and modern humans have indulged in cannibalism. And we see this in a number of Neanderthal sites where you find
该遗址尼安德特人的骨骼表明他们可能一直在近亲繁殖，因此这对人群的遗传健康不利。所以在某些时候，尼安德特人面临着挑战。还有一个棘手的问题，那就是同类相食。我们还没谈到那个，但我们知道尼安德特人和现代人类都曾有过同类相食的行为。我们在许多尼安德特人遗址中都看到了这一点，在那里你会发现
human remains of Neanderthals with cut marks on them. So these individuals have been defleshed. And so is that for consumption? Is it some kind of ritual behavior, ritual treatment of the dead? So are they are they eating their enemies or is it more a tribute to the dead? And those are both possibilities. I mean, the thing about that is that it, again, it's like a kind of Rorschach test.
带有切割痕迹的尼安德特人人类遗骸。所以这些个体的肉被剔除了。那么这是为了消费吗？这是某种仪式行为、对死者的仪式处理吗？所以他们是在吃敌人，还是更多地是对死者的敬意？这两者都是可能的。我的意思是，关于这一点，它再次类似于一种罗夏克墨迹测验。
Do you think that humans are naturally good or bad, savage and violent? Or do you think that they care for the dead and whatever? Maybe it's both, a bit of both. But I mean, it is a kind of philosophical divide, isn't it? Yeah, I mean, I simply don't know the answer to that.
你认为人类生来是善良的还是邪恶的、野蛮暴力的？还是你认为他们关心死者等等？也许两者兼而有之，两者的结合。但我的意思是，这是一种哲学上的分歧，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，我根本不知道这个问题的答案。
And you've certainly, if you speak to an archaeologist, you know, you will get both sides of the story there, that there is a view that one reason why we survived is that we were less aggressive within our groups, that we were friendlier, survival of the friendliest. Really? Yeah. I find that very counterintuitive.
如果你和考古学家谈论，你肯定会听到故事的两个方面：有一种观点认为，我们能够生存下来的原因之一是我们在自己的群体内部不那么具攻击性，我们更友善，“最友善者的生存”。真的吗？是的。我觉得这与直觉非常不符。
Within our groups. Okay. Within our groups, I say. Of course, outside your group is a different story apparently and so modern humans were able to build larger numbers of people with friendly relations within that group a reduction of aggression and the neanderthals and these other humans had lower at higher levels of interpersonal aggression and we managed to reduce that and that was part of the reason for our success now these are just obviously ideas and i'm not capable or even competent to judge whether
在我们自己的群体内部。好吧。我说的是在我们自己的群体内部。当然，在你的群体之外则是另一回事了。显然，现代人类能够通过该群体内部的友好关系建立更大数量的人群，减少攻击性，而尼安德特人和其他人类的群体间攻击性水平更高，而我们设法减少了这一点，这就是我们成功的部分原因。现在这些显然只是想法，我没有能力甚至没有资格去判断
that those ideas are correct but it's certainly one possibility that's fascinating though because it challenges the idea that is so common in popular culture that humanity that homo sapiens succeeded because of our unpleasantness you know that we were more cunning and more cruel and all these kinds of things yes i mean that's back to the inheritors image of course that you know we we basically killed off the neanderthals um and there is a view that uh around that yeah we we kind of killed them off in some long-term warfare but the coexistence in europe and asia from 60 000 to 40 000 that's at least 20 000 years of some kind of coexistence of the two groups including what we now know are
这些想法是否正确，但这绝对是一种可能性。但这太迷人了，因为它挑战了流行文化中非常普遍的观点，即人类之所以成功，是因为我们的不友善——你知道的，我们更狡猾、更残忍，以及所有这些类型的事情。是的，我的意思是，这当然又回到了《继承者》（The Inheritors）的形象，你知道，我们基本上消灭了尼安德特人。有一种观点认为，大约在那时，是的，我们在某种长期战争中消灭了他们。但在欧洲和亚洲，从6万年前到4万年前，这至少有2万年的某种形式的两个群体的共存，包括我们现在所知的
multiple examples of interbreeding between the two groups so you know it's certainly not uh you know instantaneous aggression and warfare and uh you know i often think that you know, instantaneous aggression and warfare. And, you know, I often think that, you know, the extinction of the Neanderthals was kind of a, it could even be accidental. It wasn't intentional. So, you know, orangutans in Southeast Asia are going extinct, not because people want them to go extinct, but, you know, we're removing their food, we're removing their living sites,
这两个群体之间多次通婚的例子。所以，你知道，这绝对不是……你知道，瞬间的攻击和战争。而且，你知道，我经常认为，你知道，尼安德特人的灭绝是一种……它甚至可能是偶然的。这不是故意的。所以，你知道，东南亚的猩猩正在走向灭绝，不是因为人们想让它们灭绝，而是因为我们在剥夺它们的食物，我们在剥夺它们的居住地，
we're removing their environments, and they are going extinct. We didn't intend it, but it happens. And that's what's happened to so many species probably around the world. I'm sure when people arrived in New Zealand, their first intention wasn't to kill off all the large native birds, but that's what happened. And so the extinction of the Neanderthals, at least the physical extinction, by collecting the same plant resources, by wanting to live in the best cave sites, automatically they were doing that to the detriment of the Neanderthals.
我们正在剥夺他们的环境，他们正在灭绝。我们并非有意为之，但事情就这样发生了。这大概就是世界各地许多物种发生的事情。我敢说，当人们到达新西兰时，他们的初衷并不是要杀光所有大型本土鸟类，但事情就是这样发生的。因此，尼安德特人的灭绝——至少是物理上的灭绝——通过收集相同的植物资源，通过想要住在最好的洞穴遗址中，他们在不知不觉中对尼安德特人造成了损害。
Maybe we impacted on Neanderthals in the way that we impacted on megafauna across the world, that we may not even deliberately have hunted them or anything, but that we just... Yeah, that's right. Do you think that's the likeliest explanation? I mean, there are claims that there are a couple of examples of interpersonal violence that could be between a neanderthal and a sapiens but i don't think those are sure for me they could equally be neanderthals that are you know there's a one of the shanidar neanderthals has a has a wound on one of his ribs that's partly healed because they had spears right yeah they had
也许我们对尼安德特人的影响，就像我们对世界各地大型动物群的影响一样，我们甚至可能没有故意猎杀他们之类的，但我们只是……是的，对。你认为这是最可能的解释吗？我的意思是，有人声称存在几个双人暴力冲突的例子，可能发生在尼安德特人和智人之间，但我不认为这些是确定的。对我来说，它们同样可能是尼安德特人，你知道的，沙尼达尔的其中一个尼安德特人的一根肋骨上有个部分愈合的伤口，因为他们有长矛，对吧？是的，他们有长矛。
spears so you know someone said well that maybe that's a modern human doing that well we have no idea and equally it could have been a neanderthal doing it it could even have been a hunting accident you know we can't be sure um of the cause there so what we can say is that you're beginning to find increasing evidence of these groups in close proximity we don't have the dating precision to say that they're actually there at the same time but the fact the interbreeding happened on multiple occasions means those populations must have been in close proximity and partners are moving for whatever reason between one group and the other and and those children those hybrid children they're being brought up within a modern human group and they're and they're continuing you know in that group and they're breeding on in that room
所以，你知道，有人说，好吧，也许那是现代人干的。嗯，我们一无所知。同样，这也可能是尼安德特人干的，甚至可能是一起狩猎事故，你知道，我们无法确定原因。所以，我们可以说的是，你开始发现越来越多的证据表明这些群体处于密切接触状态。我们没有年代测定精度来证明他们实际上同时在那里，但发生过多次通婚这一事实意味着这些种群必定处于密切接触状态，伴侣出于某种原因在不同群体之间移动，并且这些孩子——那些混血儿——是在现代人类群体中抚养长大的，他们并且在那个群体中延续下去，并在那个群体中繁衍。
just a question we're i think we're very close to the end now aren't we tom but um just a question about the the afterlife of the neanderthals so two of our listeners sent in questions about um whether they live on a myths and legends stephan jensen and metaburbia whether after the neanderthals sort of physically vanished from the scene whether they lived on as giants trolls orcs all these things which are there in almost all myths and kind of folkloric stories do you think there could be some kind of vestige of a time when we walk the earth together a jungian memory yeah exactly yeah i mean it's obviously going to have to be very deep time because we're talking 40 000 years and for me that's a difficult thing to to establish but
只是一个问题，我想我们现在已经非常接近尾声了，对吧，汤姆？但是……关于尼安德特人的来世，我们的两位听众发送了关于……关于他们是否作为神话和传说流传下来的问题——斯特凡·延森（Stephan Jensen）和梅塔伯比亚（Metaburbia）——在尼安德特人从场景中物理消失之后，他们是否作为巨人、巨魔、兽人活了下来？所有这些几乎存在于所有神话和民俗故事中的事物。你认为可能存在某种我们曾共同漫步地球的时代的痕迹吗？一种荣格式的记忆？是的，完全正确。是的。我的意思是，这显然必须是很久以前的事情了，因为我们在谈论4万年，对我来说，这是一个很难确定的事情，但是
bjorn katen a paleontologist he wrote a series of novels also about the neanderthal modern human interface and interaction and they are really good as well. And I recommend them. One called Dance of the Tiger. And in there, the modern humans call the Neanderthals trolls. That is their name for them. So, you know, there is that implication there that this particularly Kurtem was from Scandinavia.
古生物学家比约恩·卡滕（Bjorn Kurten）写了一系列关于尼安德特人与现代人类交界面和相互作用的小说，它们也非常棒。我推荐它们。其中一本叫《老虎之舞》（Dance of the Tiger）。在那里，现代人类称尼安德特人为“巨魔”（trolls）。那是他们对他们的称呼。所以，你知道，这其中有一种暗示，即这个特别是库滕来自斯堪的纳维亚半岛。
So that's where that legend, those legends are very strong. It would be odd if there weren't a kind of buried memory somewhere deep within us that there were once you know other creatures who were like us but were not us if you know what I mean do you not think it's a long time and the same applies over in Flores so in Flores we've got this weird the hobbits creature you know nicknamed the hobbit homo floresiensis and was around until, probably around until 50,000 years ago. And there are folk tales of strange little creatures living in the woods in Southeast Asia. Are those some kind of memories from 40,000 years ago of the hobbit? Or are they actually referring to the orangutan or the gibbon or some other creatures that live in the woods?
所以这就是那个传说、那些传说非常强烈的地方。如果在我们内心深处的某个地方，没有一种埋藏的记忆，即曾经存在过其他像我们但又不是我们的生物（如果你懂我的意思的话），那将是奇怪的。你不认为这是一段很长的时间吗？弗洛雷斯岛上的情况也是如此，在弗洛雷斯，我们有这个奇怪的“霍比特人”生物（绰号为霍比特人，弗洛勒斯人），它一直存在到大约5万年前。东南亚的树林里流传着关于生活在树林里的奇怪小生物的民间传说。这些是4万年前关于霍比特人的某种记忆吗？还是它们实际上是指生活在树林里的猩猩、长臂猿或其他生物？
So I think those memories are certainly there but for me that's such deep time yeah i i don't know that really there could be a survival like that chris before we go just one last question do you have any sense have have people begun to think about whether in the wake of the pandemic whether the neanderthals might have been wiped out by some pandemic perhaps is this something that is starting to surface in neanderthals might have been wiped out by some pandemic, perhaps. Is this something that is starting to surface in Neanderthal studies? Yes, I mean, that has come up that, you know, we had evolved in Africa, the Neanderthals had been evolving in Europe and Asia. So we could have brought diseases from Africa that the Neanderthals had no immunity to. And that's
所以我认为这些记忆当然是存在的，但对我不而言，那是太久远的历史了。是的，我不知道是否真的会有那样的生存。克里斯，在我们离开之前，最后一个问题：你有没有这种感觉——人们是否开始考虑，在大流行之后，尼安德特人是否可能被某种大流行消灭了？这是否开始在尼安德特人研究中浮出水面？是的，我的意思是，这确实被提出过，你知道，我们在非洲进化，尼安德特人在欧洲和亚洲进化。所以我们可能从非洲带来了尼安德特人没有免疫力的疾病。这
been proposed. Certainly, there could have been those, there proposed. Certainly, if the populations are in contact, then there could certainly be an exchange of pathogens and parasites between them. But of course, many of the examples in recent history, for example, in South America, of where epidemics were carried from one population to another, those populations are living at quite high density. And so there can can be a rapid spread as we have with covid today we're talking about much smaller groups spaced out on the landscape so i'm not sure yeah how much that could have run through a whole population and finish them off and what's interesting is the inverse that actually obviously having evolved in africa we didn't have any immunity to the diseases outside of Africa.
已经被提出。当然，可能会有这些……被提出。当然，如果人群处于接触状态，那么他们之间肯定会发生病原体和寄生虫的交换。但是，当然，近代史上的许多例子，例如在南美洲，流行病从一个人群传播到另一个人群，那些人群生活在相当高的密度下。因此可能会迅速传播，就像我们今天遇到新冠病毒一样。我们谈论的是分布在景观中相距较远的更小的群体，所以我不确定这能在多大程度上穿透整个人群并消灭他们。有趣的是相反的情况：显然，由于在非洲进化，我们对非洲以外的疾病没有任何免疫力。
The Neanderthals, having evolved there, had evolved natural immunities to many of the local diseases. And it seems likely that one of the advantages, if you like, of interbreeding with Neanderthals was we picked up some of their immune systems. And so maybe that's why early waves of Homo sapiens failed to settle. Well, yeah, I mean, they may have just been too small in number, and they couldn't cope with the climate changes any better than the Neanderthals could, and they just disappeared again. But yeah, I think that, you know, by interbreeding with Neanderthals, we got a quick fix to our immune systems outside of Africa, and that helped us survive. Because it's still
尼安德特人在那里进化，对许多地方性疾病进化出了自然免疫力。看起来，与尼安德特人通婚的优势之一，如果你愿意这么说的话，就是我们获得了一些他们的免疫系统。所以也许这就是为什么早期智人浪潮未能定居的原因。嗯，是的，我的意思是，他们的数量可能太少了，他们应对气候变化的能力并不比尼安德特人好，他们就再次消失了。但是，是的，我认为，通过与尼安德特人通婚，我们对非洲以外的免疫系统进行了快速修复，这帮助我们生存了下来。因为这仍然
impacting on COVID, isn't it? It's claimed that there are some variants which have derived from Neanderthals which improve your resistance to COVID and others which act against it. And it's been even claimed that in different, because of course Neanderthal DNA is spread right across everyone outside of Africa,
对新冠病毒产生影响，不是吗？据称，有些变体源自尼安德特人，可以提高你对新冠病毒的抵抗力，而另一些变体则起到相反的作用。甚至有人声称，在不同的……因为尼安德特人的DNA确实分布在非洲以外的所有人身上，
has it in the Americas, in Australia, in Europe and so on. So certainly those different variants could actually be helping or hindering the spread of COVID in modern human populations. So yeah, it's quite possible. So yes, the Neanderthal DNA is affecting our immune systems outside of Africa, and still is today. And it's possible that some autoimmune conditions are also linked with the presence of Neanderthal DNA. So in a sense, their immune systems are too active and they even turn in on themselves.
美洲、澳大利亚、欧洲等等的人都有。因此，这些不同的变体实际上可能在现代人类群体中有助于或阻碍新冠病毒的传播。所以，是的，这很有可能。所以，是的，尼安德特人的DNA正在影响我们非洲以外的免疫系统，并且直到今天仍然如此。某些自身免疫性疾病也可能与尼安德特人DNA的存在有关。从某种意义上说，他们的免疫系统过于活跃，甚至开始攻击自身。
And that's also a possibility. So they're not just prehistory. I think that is absolutely the perfect note on which to end. And Chris, thanks so much for that. Can't thank you enough. Thomas, you want to do your impersonation now? We hope you've enjoyed listening to this episode of the rest is history and we'll look forward to
这也是一种可能。所以他们不仅仅是史前历史。我认为这绝对是结束本集的完美音符。克里斯，非常感谢你。感激不尽。汤姆，你想现在开始你的模仿秀吗？我们希望你喜欢收听本期《剩余历史》，我们期待着
seeing you next week bye bye goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周再见。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《剩余历史》。如需获取额外单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。